at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
oock hey you guys what's going on it's
Wednesday night time for the main show I
haven't touched it so it was just off a
little bit now it's okay whatever good
well I was off off the screen well I I
don't know what to tell you um some of
you guys are talking about wickerman cuz
somebody said they' just seen it for the
first time I'm presuming me in the
original one um yeah we did Cover
wickerman a long time ago I don't think
we've done the um I don't think we've
done the um silly remake one was
Nicholas Cage which actually I didn't
mind I didn't think it was that bad but
oh it's terrible but it's um not like to
the original I mean it's so bad it's
good though yeah but we haven't done
that one but we have done the original
cuz the original wicker man is one my
favorite movies of all time but yeah so
I don't remember how long ago it was
that we covered it but it was a long
time ago um yeah Camp guy said I enjoyed
the both yeah I mean for different
reasons
obviously for different reasons so yeah
um this topic tonight what a great topic
this is I had actually never really
heard about this case prior to somebody
recommended this to me like a long time
ago and I can't remember who it was I
want to say it was Victor but I'm not
really sure so whoever it is if if it
was you like let me know but it was a
while back cuz I kept putting in the
poll and it never won but it finally won
this week and I kind of got into the
case I watched like a whole bunch of
documentaries about it there's a whole
bunch of books about it and [__] like
that so it's like really really
interesting so we're going to cover that
uh this evening so like I said I can't
really remember who it was that
recommended it first but whoever it was
like thank you because this is actually
a really good topic and I might not have
come to this on my own because I don't
really uh I hadn't heard of it prior to
that murder Hornet said back in Texas
just came from Florida five hours ago
yep it was actually like pretty nice in
Florida today yeah he was up the
panle that's kind of far from us though
it's real far yeah today it was only 59°
fhe which means that native Floridians
other than me are going around wearing
sweaters andit yeah they think it's
cold seriously it's been like 60° before
and I have legit seen like native
Floridians wearing parkas and stuff it's
ridiculous I know it's not cold though
it's not well no and like I said I was
born in Florida but I love this weather
I was out today in my in my sleeveless
shirt going woo it's so nice and cool
out yeah you know I've been at Sub-Zero
temperatures I know it's not cold
but they got something their their point
of view their metabolism is is is wonky
because they've lived in the South their
whole life but I'll tell you what
Mississippi got cold in the winter you
know it it would freeze and it was the
the the temperature the the humidity is
100% so if you when you when you have
high humidity and cold it's just
penetrating it's very real
cold but you know it's 30° Fahrenheit
20° you almost freezing it does freeze
here every night and then maybe once or
twice a year but not not very often I
think last year we had one night that
was that went below freezing but that's
about it I remember when it snowed that
was in 2009 when that 2009 yeah I've L
I've seen snow in Florida like once or
twice but it's not like snow snow where
it's on the ground it's just kind of
like oh look little flakes of snow for a
second they just like melt when no it's
stuck here it's stuck on Mount Dora cuz
I went there and saw the damn lights and
the snow went toured through it it stuck
on the ground sometimes in the central
part of the state it gets slightly
colder and because I was still living on
the coast at that time and it just melt
over there it didn't stick uh on the
road you know what I mean it just turned
into water yeah but all the Lawns and
everything it was it was covered in
snow lasted about a week and it all
melted I never heard of that happening
yeah up Mount Dora like I said that must
that's the central part of the state I
was living on the co at the time and it
never scks over there you would just
kind of see the the flakes floating
around in the air you know what I mean
look like Boston that's crazy for about
five
days so yeah I wasn't living over here
then so cuz usually if it gets real cold
it'll be like somewhere like Okala or
somewhere like that like way in the
middle of it it was a high that was a
really unusual Winter though well yeah
for Florida that's it's like once every
50 years it does that yeah John gor said
I watched uh the skull from 1965 by
Terrence Fischer had Peter Cushing and
uh Christopher Lee corny movie but
gorgeous looking yeah we covered that
one not too long ago I think correct me
if I'm wrong but wasn't that an amicus
like one of the well I don't want to say
one of the few movies but one of the
movies that Amicus did that was not an
anthology it was actually pretty good I
I didn't mind it I think we reviewed it
a few months back cuz I remember
watching it not that long ago either
that or I just reviewed it I just
remember watching it talking about it
not too long ago that's all I'm saying
but uh yeah so before we get into the
topic let's do some of our little
affiliate stuff here uh so today our uh
affiliate marketing partner that we're
talking about we're going to be talking
about
skillshare so this is a repository of
online classes uh generally anything
creative that you want to do if you want
to start your own YouTube channel or if
you want to write a novel or if you want
to learn learn to paint or whatever it
is uh there's all just thousands and
thousands of classes on there taught by
professional instructors in everything
from music production to figure drawing
to marketing video editing graphic
design pretty much any creative thing
that you would want to learn to do uh
there's somebody on there that will
teach you how to do it and they have all
kind of classes ranging from beginners
to experts so be sure and check my
referral Link in the description box uh
for one free month of skillshare so this
is full disclosure obviously of course
we are skillshare Affiliates so we get a
small commission whenever you purchase
through that link but there is a link in
the description box please click it and
subscribe to skillshare you get one free
month all right so this case I love old
timey crime [__] you know what I mean
like Victorian era stuff like early 20th
Century stuff I don't know there's just
something like really cool about it and
this case I guess there's a lot of
reasons why it's so famous cuz like I
said even though I hadn't previously
heard of it there's tons of books about
it there was all these documentaries
about it uh you know it was kind of a
big
deal um I think it's because one it was
one of the worst miscarriages of Justice
in uh Scottish legal history also
because the murder itself like at the
center of it is still unsolved like they
don't know who actually did it and uh
thirdly because you know famously Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle was somewhat involved
in um helping the innocent person uh who
had been wrongfully accused get free uh
he wasn't the only person that helped
cuz the guy had a lot of help but you
know what I mean but the fact that he
was so famous and his name was attached
to it that helped a great deal you know
what I mean uh yeah it was Amicus that's
what I thought cuz I I remember cuz I
know Amicus mostly from their Anthology
films but they did make a lot of movies
that weren't Anthology films and this
skull was one of them so are you ready
to start the [__] or do you have
something else you need to talk to talk
about first or NOP something like that
um yeah hold on I'm just like oh Tammy
said that she made the pumpkin pie
recipe out of your book yesterday and
it's pretty good yeah
yeah then Camp guy said something I was
not aware of I recently saw a podcast
about uh Danny Rowling and it said that
he was horribly abused as a very young
child by both his stepfather and in
school when he got older yeah I don't
did we do a show about Danny Rowling the
Gainesville Ripper uh I thought we had
because I don't remember it I
remember well when he was doing his
murders I had several friends at the
University of Florida where he was
killing people and a bunch of them came
came home like a bunch of people did cuz
they were like [__] this we're not
staying on this campus anymore cuz
there's a [__] serial killer running
around so I remember that happening cuz
I was like early 90s right because I had
a you know so you know University of
Florida is in Gainesville and that's
like one of the big uh universities that
a lot of people that graduate in
anywhere in Central Florida will go to
so I had a lot of friends there like
right around the time that that was
going on and a lot of them came home but
I yeah I don't I thought we had and I'd
be shocked if we didn't do a show about
him but if we didn't we should probably
but I thought we had you have to look
back in the inventory I don't remember
that one yeah like I said we've done so
many shows that it's like I can't keep
them all straight some of them I've
forgotten you know I had zanada who's a
I talk to him regularly on messenger
going back and listening to surviving a
disaster episode we did and that was a
couple years ago I think yeah everybody
liked that show it got a lot of good
comments on it a lot of hits on it uh
some people even asked me to [__] do
a part two of that yeah we could do a
revisit on revisit on I throw that in
the poll how to survive the
apocalypse murder Hornet said Tom was
the Zodiac Killer oh [__] did I say that
out loud yeah I'm a little young zodiac
Killer's dead man yeah he he was the
Zodiac Killer when he was a baby yeah
when I was a baby
yeah he was he was a serial killer baby
yeah has anybody made a movie like that
was [__] three yeah
yeah you run around like a toddler like
shooting people that would have been the
driving cars at three sitting on a box
yeah making ciphers to the police at
three you're pretty smart Tom yeah I'm
[__] smart
but he's like a genius and he three
years yeah at three I'm a serial killer
making codes that they barely cracked
just recently
yeah maybe that's why maybe they're too
easy because it came from like a child's
brain yeah see I'm going to write a book
about I'm going to write a book with
that theory and sell a million copies CU
even though I'm just going to pull a
bunch of stuff out of my ass my husband
is is the
sod that have been like
Chucky running around in ashkash
BOS oh [__] man tough skin jeans green
ones yeah there you go yeah from like
73 yeah I know like the Zodiac Shop
people that people but
yeah sorry we both colds so kind of bear
with us a little bit if I have a
coughing fit or some [__] like that
actually about an hour ago I had like a
really bad sneezing fit I just sneezed
and sneezed and SE I thought it was
never going to end Camp guy said uh gasy
was abused keer was abused P panzram was
abused yeah I mean not all of them were
but the large majority of serial killers
were indeed abused those children not
that that excuses what they do as an
adults obviously because a lot of people
were abused as children and grew up to
be perfectly fine but you know you beat
a you beat on a dog man you'll make that
dog mean same people the same way some
of them will just become real mean yeah
yeah so you know although there are
exceptions to the rule like some serial
killers grow up you know in totally
normal yeah families um but I think the
majority of them did have [__] up [__]
happened to them as children I think a
lot of them were more like uh uh dmer I
think a lot of them are kind of like
that where they're just more like
neglected than they are abused they're
just kind of left to their own viices
and they're end up going getting into
these weird perversions Power Trip stuff
and they start having these fantasies
they can't control I think that's most
of
them I don't think most of them were
abused High Desert says what were those
killer baby movies from the 70s called
uh it's alive uh the first one's great
actually yeah yeah the it's alive movies
are pretty good killer baby films the
first two yeah I like I the first one I
love that's like actually one of my
favorite movies of the 70s it's a real
good lowbudget 70s it's great it's great
I love it um that one also ends in the
[__] California storm drains yeah
that's right I think it did they had to
go down there to go wear all the big
giant ants lived in
them baby went down in there yeah Ira
said if either of you heard about
China's Jack the Ripper GA Chang Yong he
was Notorious in the country while he
was active I have not but I'm going to
write that down because I need to look
what year was that I need to look that
up the Chinese river yeah every
country's got to have one I guess
somebody we all got to have [__] up
serial killers but yeah let me write
that down I can put that in our on our
topic list because I want to look that
up
okay so yeah Danny ring said I blame
World War II PTSD on the family abuse
back in the day yeah because it just
wasn't seen it was seen as it was pretty
normalized I feel like up until what
the' 60s or 70s like beating on your
kids beating on your wife stuff like
that I don't really think any anybody
thought that much about it you know
which is uh not great cuz you know
obviously that's um gonna screw people
up uh Jen Allen said I made the live and
Kenny D said caught the live stream at
last yeah here we are glad you guys are
all here glad you all made it like I
said uh if you just are joining us uh
we're both a little bit sick so I'm not
on any medication at the moment but I do
feel kind of weird like laded I don't
feel terrible but I just kind of have
I've just been like coughing and stuff
like that all right so let's start the
story with the
murder so it's December 21st
1908 and this is in uh Glasgow in
Scotland so it's about 7:00 in the
evening and there's this young woman who
she works as a maid her name is Helen
lambi uh some sources said that she was
known as Nelly also but I'm just going
to call her
Helen so she actually goes out she
worked for this elderly lady named Mary
and Gil Chris who was 83 years
old she goes out about 7 o' to go out
and like pick up food and pick up the
newspaper for the day and stuff like
that was something she did pretty much
every day you know what I mean uh this
flat was on uh Queen's Terrace which I
believe is now known as West Prince's
street now interestingly um later I
think like in the 1960s somebody wrote a
book about this they kind of christened
this area glasgow's square mile of
murder because four of Scotland's most
infamous murders happened like in this
very small like square mile just I don't
know coincidentally or whatever because
the murders weren't related to each
other but they all just kind of happened
in this small area so this area is
actually known as the square mile of
murder so as I said this maid Helen she
went every day about 7:00 and go get the
newspapers and you know go to the shops
for food or whatever for her employer
who is Miss Gilchrist this usually took
her about 10
minutes during the 10 minutes that she
was
gone Miss Gilchrist was horribly
brutally
murdered now Mary and Gilchrist uh she
was a very very wealthy woman she was uh
unmarried I don't believe she had
married uh I could be wrong about that
she lived in uh this flat it was on see
most of the um this always confuses me
because most of the sources right it
said she lived in a first floor flat now
in the United States that would mean she
lived on the ground floor right but in
the UK that means the second floor
because they say ground floor first
floor which like I said to me is very
confusing yeah it was like that in
Brazil yeah so I the first floor was t t
ground floor yeah and it's usually
that's it's because that's where at
least in in Old Brazilian buildings the
ones that you know I was growing up in
that's where the doorman was and all the
the staff right they lived on or they
didn't live there they manned it and
nobody lived on on floor on the ground
floor it's where security was right
basically yeah this particular building
at least and it's still there the
building I believe it's been converted
into uh flats for students at this uh
stage or at least like as far as like
the documentary that I watched cuz they
went to the actual place where it
happened and there were like some
students living there and they said hey
a lady got murdered in here and what's
now your bedroom how do you feel about
that but you know what I mean um so yeah
so she lived on what Americans would
call the second floor and then there was
um a guy and his sisters living below
her and then I believe the flat above
them was empty so Mary and Gilchrist
like I said very very wealthy woman she
had inherited a very large estate from
her dad who I believe was an engineer or
something um the estate that she
inherited is estimated to be between 6
and 8 million pound in today's money uh
or in American dollars that would be
between 7 and half and10 million so she
was quite
Rich so as I mentioned living on the
ground floor flat and these were nice
Flats you know what I mean it wasn't
just like some little squalled pit you
know what I mean they were like really
big so living on the ground floor was a
professional musician by the name of
Arthur Adams and his sisters some
sources said he had two sisters some
said he had Five Sisters I don't know
how many sisters were living in there
but it was more than one it was at least
two
okay now on this particular evening
December
21st Arthur Adams and the sisters heard
a thud on the ceiling and then they
heard three
knocks now these three knocks that they
heard this was a like a pre-arranged
signal they had set up between them and
Mary and Gilchrist who lived upstairs
because like I said the lady was older
uh and as we'll discover she was a
little bit security conscious or maybe
even paranoid so she was like Hey if
anything ever goes wrong or I'm ever in
trouble I'll knock on the floor three
times and you come up and help me so
that's what it was so they heard these
three knocks and they presume oh Marian
needs help with something like something
happened
so Arthur at this point he's like okay
I'm going to go and check and see what's
going
on so he goes up to cuz the way the
building is situated I'm not entirely
clear on it I saw a plan but it doesn't
look the same now as it looked like at
the time obviously so he goes through
this door that leads to the stairs that
go up to her
flat now the door was not locked which
he thought was strange strange because
it usually was so he goes up to her door
and rang the bell but nobody answered
and he couldn't hear anything going on
in there so he Rings again but again
nobody answers now the door had glass
panels like on either side of it and so
he kind of Peaks through the glass plane
I think it was like pebbled glass you
couldn't see exactly but he said he saw
like there were gas lamps that were in
the hallway along the hallway and they
were lit so then he like rang again and
then he said he heard a sound in there
that he described as he said it sounded
like somebody chopping
sticks and at this point he's like oh
well maybe that's the maid and she's in
the kitchen and I guess everything's
okay so he left and he went back
downstairs but when he gets back down
there and he says to his sisters what
happened they were like Noah bro it's
like something weird is going on up
there you need to go back up there and
see what's the
matter so he went back up there and rang
the bell again but this time he doesn't
hear
anything then he hears somebody coming
up the stairs behind him and he turns
around and this was actually Helen the
maid she was coming back from getting
the newspapers or whatever and he said
and he kind of told her what was going
on and she was like oh it's probably
nothing she's like we have these pulley
in the kitchen that like you know
they're real squeaky like they need oil
and stuff and I just haven't got around
to doing it so that's probably what that
noise was that's probably what you heard
but it's probably fine um he's like well
regardless I'll just stay here until you
go in and see if everything's okay
because we thought we heard you know
Maran knocking for
help so Helen unlocks the door and goes
in to the kitchen cuz I think there's
like an entryway and there was like two
doors on either side at least like
according to the plan that I
saw so she goes into the kitchen
nothing's in there everything looks fine
and then then um Helen leaves the
kitchen and then a dude comes out of one
of the bedrooms like the spare bedroom
not Marian's bedroom but the other one
he comes out of this bedroom um they
described him as wearing like a light
colored Overcoat they said he looked
well-dressed like a gentleman he didn't
look like a buom or a criminal or
anything like that you know what I mean
because you know how class conscious
yeah the UK was at that time so they
said he looked like a
gentleman so this dude just walks out of
this bedroom in this flat kind of just
walks past Arthur and leaves the flat
and like walks down the
stairs and Arthur's like huh but he
wasn't alarmed because he said that
Helen lambi the maid that she wasn't
surprised to see him so Arthur just
assumed that he that she knew who he was
you know what I mean so it's like and
she wasn't like surprised like what the
[__] f are you doing in here or whatever
so he was like oh okay so I guess that's
nothing to be concerned about you know
what I
mean now Helen at this point is still in
there she's in the kitchen and she said
um like and then she kind of goes and
she saw the Dude too but like only for a
second but then she goes into the dining
room and screams her [__] head off
and she yells to Arthur like come in
here so Arthur goes in there and Mary
and Gil is laying on the floor in front
of the fireplace she had like she was
laying in a pool of blood there was a
pool of blood around her head but there
was like a rug over her
head so at this point he's like oh well
that guy must have done this that just
passed me so he runs out in the street
like looking for the guy so he runs down
the stairs and he just like looks like
both sides of but he doesn't see
anybody so um so then like while he's
down there he does find a cop that was
like you know doing his beat or whatever
and he's like oh my God somebody's you
know hurt up here like come on so the
cop comes back up they all go back in
the dining room and they take the rug
off of her head
and I saw the crime photos from this man
that poor woman was obliterated like her
head was oh my God it was awful and it's
like I was watching the documentary
about it and they didn't really warn you
like before they were going to show the
picture and I was like God damn I didn't
know I didn't expect I was going to see
that but yeah it pretty [__] up your
head was smashed huh it was pretty
busted yeah good you could see the skull
um kind of it was a black and white
picture but um so you couldn't really
tell were you the showing the back of
the head or the front of the head it was
the front of her head although I think
you could see the face yeah all right
but I think the picture the weird thing
is that the picture she was face up well
they just kind of showed the head but
then some of the sources I read said
they found her face down okay so I don't
know if the picture had been taken after
they flipped her over or what you know
what I mean
but it was pretty [__] up looking uh
regardless so yeah so she had basically
been beaten really bad like around the
head they found though that she was
actually still alive she was still
breathing so at this point Arthur like a
doctor lived across the street so he
runs out the house and goes over there
to get the doctor and brings the doctor
over unfortunately by the time the
doctor got back over there um she was
dead now the doctor when he was over
over there um he thought that the murder
weapon was
probably one of the dining room chairs
because it was just covered with blood
it was like a big heavy like wooden
chair now interestingly this will kind
of come into play later
on that this doctor the first doctor to
arrive on the scene and he's like oh
that must be the murder weapon because
it's like the chair leg had like blood
all over just a leg I'm not no it was
the whole chair but I think there was
just like blood all over the chair it's
kind of hard to use a chair as a weapon
I know well we I'll get into I'll get
into like don't jump the gun because
there's like a lot of other stuff about
this all but the thing about it is that
um so he's like well that must be have
been used to kill her because it has
blood all over it like just the pattern
of the blood and everything
interestingly this doctor and this is
whole thing that we'll get into later
but um was not called as a witness at
the trial so even though he was the
first doctor to arrive and see the body
so there you go
weird yeah well like I said we'll get
into
that so the cops get there obviously and
they start looking around the
place now there's a gas lamp in the
spare bedroom where the dude came out of
you know what I mean and it was lit and
Helen the maid said I swear I did not
light that lamp before like that wasn't
lit when I left the house to get the
newspapers um and below the lamp there
was like a like a used match and then
there was also a box of matches that
were a brand that they didn't use like
in that house or you know at least
according to the Mage she's like yeah we
don't use that brand so they thought
that was a little weird on the table
next to the matches um there was like a
tray with a bunch of jewelry on it there
was a gold watch with a chain on it and
there was also a small wooden box that
had been broken open and it had
contained like documents just like
papers and stuff like that and they said
there was just like papers all over the
place so they asked Helen well is there
anything missing like or any valubles
missing and she said the only thing that
she could see that was missing was this
diamond brooch it was like a gold moon
shape like a crescent moon like with all
with diamonds on the
outside now interestingly she said that
was the only thing that was missing now
this woman Mary and Gilchrist she
collected expensive jewelry she had
jewelry all over the [__] there was like
expensive jewelry everywhere so the fact
that that was the only thing that was
taken along with whatever paper had been
taken out of this wooden
box um would seem to preclude the uh
possibility of like robbery because
there was just money and jewelry laying
around everywhere and none of it was
taken which again is something else
we'll get back
to so they asked Callen well did you see
the guy who ran out of the flag and she
said well I just saw him for a second or
she just saw the side of his
face um what Oh I thought you were going
to say something no oh you made a thing
like you were drank some of that oh okay
she she's she's micro imagin she's
watching I'm not no it's like CU usually
that's that's the sound you make before
you say something and I thought you had
something to contribute about about this
nope situation so
far so she was like yeah I didn't really
get a good look at him and then they
asked Arthur you know the the neighbor
well did you see him and he's like well
I didn't really get that good a look of
him either because it's like I don't I
didn't have my glasses on like they you
know they're downstairs so I didn't get
a great look at him either so basically
all they could say and their
descriptions kind of matched they said
uh the man was like in his mid to late
20s he was average height 5'8 5' n
something like that um slim build dark
hair clean shaven uh had a light gray
Overcoat
and a dark cloth cap which could have
described as the one documentary I saw
it said probably described half the men
in Scotland at that
point so how old was she who the maid
the victim yeah oh the victim yeah 83
okay 83 all
right yeah she was an elderly lady all
right still pretty uh spry though by all
accounts must have been robbery um I she
was a witness to something he killed
her something like that no victim you
think you think this the motive was
sexual no okay all right we'll see well
I know about this so like I said you're
trying to like you you only have like
tiny bits of evidence in your AR try to
like figure it out when you don't know
all the stuff okay smarty pants no I'm
just saying all right no I'm just saying
why you trying to figure it out tell fit
sexual offense it fits more like
something like robbery so far I'm just
trying to right I'm just saying that
well that was what the thought too only
nothing was taken other than that one
thing and some kind of hit but we yeah
we'll get into that okay so what they
decided to do was they had this very
vague description of this dude who was
seen leaving the apartment of the flat
rather and they sent them to all the
pawn shops in the area because obviously
they thought someone was going to try
and pawn that diamond Broach right which
was the only thing that had been the
only valuable thing apparently that had
been taken from the apartment
now later that night apparently Helen
went down the street to tell um Mary and
Gilchrist niece whose name was uh
Margaret Burell uh what had happened
like about the
murder now as I okay so the cops from
the beginning they were like okay this
probably was somebody that Mary and
Gilchrist knew um either you know a clo
a family member or somebody she knew
because she was very like I said
security conscious and paranoid and
would not have let somebody in that she
didn't know and there was no sign of
forced entry
right um they looked into her maid Helen
lambi uh they were like you know do you
have any boyfriends or acquaintances
that you might have told that Mary and
Gilchrist had all of this expensive
jewelry in the flat maybe they broke in
maybe Helen lambi like let them in or
something like that they couldn't really
find anything along those lines either
cuz like I said said the thing about it
was that Maran
had just there was jewelry like laying
out in her house but she also had a
bunch of it hidden in there too uh there
were even rumors that she sewn some of
it into her curtains and it was like
under the mattresses and it's like she
had it everywhere right now at the time
they estimated that she had in those
days money 3,000 lb worth of Jewelry in
her flat which in today's money would be
almost half of million pounds or about
$560,000 in American money um of Jewelry
in her house none of which was taken
like I said other than that one
broch um so yeah and that was kind of
why she had all that stuff in there and
that was kind of why she was like afraid
of burglars and [__] like that and
that's why she had the whole knocking
thing with her neighbors downstairs and
[__] like that right cuz she was kind of
paranoid about
it so a few days go by and the cops
don't really have any
leads but then this 14-year-old girl
named Mary
baroman came to the police uh at the
behest of her
mother and said oh I was walking along
West Prince's street where the Mary and
Gilchrist house was uh at about 10
minutes past 7 and I saw the guy like he
almost ran into
me and the problem was that
that the description she gave of the guy
was completely different than the
description that Arthur and Helen had
given to the police she said that the
dude was 28 to 30 tall thin uh also
clean shaven uh nose kind of large or
like bent to one
side uh had a fawn colored Overcoat
believed on uh that was uh waterproof
they thought
dark pants a cloth cap made out of Tweed
and like a dark colored one and brown
boots that's close though kind of but
like I said don't jump the gun too much
but like I said because the descriptions
were different the cops were like well
maybe it's two guys you know what I mean
so they put both the descriptions they
published them in the paper and that was
on Christmas day of
1908 also fatefully as it would turn out
uh on Christmas Day the cops also got a
statement from a guy named Alan mlan who
was like he ran like a bicycle
shop and he had read in the paper about
the stolen Diamond
brooch and he said to the cops he's like
oh there's this guy who goes to a
gambling club that I go to and he had
been trying to sell a pawn ticket for a
diamond brooch like you know not too
long ago so he's like I don't I only
know the guy's first name but I know
where his house is so he's like so I'll
show you where his house is the dude's
first name is
Oscar so he takes the cops to this house
which is on St George's
road now on the outside of the house
there was a little metal plate thing you
know that says what the people's name is
but this
plate said a Anderson
dentist it wasn't a dentist office
though it was somebody's
house and the house belonged to a man
named Oscar
Slater now Oscar Slater was not his real
name uh his real name was actually uh
Oscar with a K Joseph ner I think is how
you pronounce his last name or something
like
that he was actually originally from uh
uh Opel I'm not really sure how you
pronounce that either which uh upper
Silesia which at the time was part of
Germany I believe now it's part of
Poland so he was uh originally was from
a Jewish Family and was born in
1872 now he left Germany in
1893 possibly to escape military service
uh which a lot of German dudes were
doing around that
era and he then moved to London
now while in London he worked as a
bookie pretty much uh and he went under
various pseudonyms like he tried to kind
of hide his Heritage a little bit uh so
he kind of had some angelized names uh
in and Anderson was one of his last
names he usually kept Oscar as his first
name but he had like different more
English sounding last names um but
eventually he just went by Oscars later
now he had he was a little bit kind of
known to the police he actually had been
in London rather he was arrested in 1896
for malicious wounding I'm not really
entirely sure what that entails uh and
in 1897 he was arrested for assault but
in both of those cases he was
acquitted now in 1899 he moved to
Edinburgh Scotland and then in 1901 he
had moved to Glasgow
now he was kind of known to
be um kind of a Dandy you know what I
mean like he was he always looked real
slick and
everything now he told people he he
seemed like a little bit of a Flim Flam
man little bit like he would sometimes
tell people he was a dentist um or he
was a gem
dealer but most people um you know most
modern sources think that he probably
just made his living as a gambler you
know what I mean
now it should be noted I'm not exactly
sure about the laws
but cuz you know gambling laws are weird
in the us too but like in the UK I
believe you can go
to you know there's there's legalized
gambling you know what I mean where you
can just go to the bookmaker or whatever
and you can do bets and everything now
you could do that back then too but then
I think they kind of a lot of people
would just like do it in the streets it
was like freelance gambling
and I think they kind of passed a law
and cracked down on that but people
still did it anyway government couldn't
get their cut yeah so it was just it was
that kind of
thing now so that was they're probably
they're sure that that's probably how he
was making his money like I said he was
a little bit of a like a flimflam man
confidence man he was just like a
gambler you know what I mean now when he
moved to Glasgow he actually lived uh
unmarried with his mistress now his
mistress was a French woman uh an
actress and likely prostitute uh whose
name was Andre
Antoine now Oscar had actually been
married previously and technically I
guess legally still was but he had
abandoned his wife years prior because
she was a bad alcoholic and she like
just spent money like it was nothing and
stuff like that so he just like took off
and left her it's so funny countries
that uh don't have legalized divorce
people just do whatever they want anyway
I was I saw a thing like on the
Philippines
divorce is illegal there but they they
break up anyway and then they just they
get new wives and [__] they just don't
it's just not on paper yeah I mean
that's the thing you can't make people
you can't make people stay together stay
together if they don't want to and you
shouldn't right I mean you know what I
mean yeah foreign guys moved down there
retired and [__] they're they're looking
for divorced Filipino women in their
late 20s early 30s so those are the ones
you really want to go because they're
already married yeah so you know what I
mean they they they can't really legally
get married again so they shack up right
they shack up that's all they want shack
up with a good man and take care of them
that's all I understand I understand it
you know yeah better than being single
the rest of your life yeah I mean that's
and what seems to have happened here um
is that I don't know if he just didn't
want to bother going through a divorce
or if it's just like too much trouble or
he's just like [__] it I'm just going to
like take off and change my name again
so she can't find me or something like
that the United States
really I think divorce really that
really kind of became a common thing
mostly like in the 70s but people got
divorced anyway yeah and a lot of times
half the times illegally they just moved
yeah if you moved to another state
especially early 1900s you could get
married as many times as you wanted as
long as you kept moving yeah if you move
from state to state because prior to the
Advent of them like keeping records from
state to state like as long as you
weren't drawing attention to yourself I
don't think anybody would notice yeah
they would notice as long as there were
no complaints really and they had they
had to track you down yeah somebody had
to like bring charges against it they
found out some [__] yeah most people
didn't care I don't think yeah like I
said as long as you weren't like drawing
attention to yourself as long as you
weren't like murdering people or
stealing all their money or something
like that like then yeah then they'd go
after you but yeah if you were just like
I don't really want to be with this
person anymore I'm going to move to
right Oregon and like marry this other
person like I don't think anybody would
complain yeah unless somebody brought
charges so so yeah so apparently how
these two lived was he would go out at
night and gamble for money and she would
have men over to the house you know what
I mean make some money which like I said
got to make some money I'm not I'm not
getting all a case or nothing like
that so the cops were very happy about
this because they're like woo look at
this scumbag you know what I mean it was
like a gambler he hangs out with
prostitutes uh and and apparently he did
Pawn a diamond
brooch so he goes to the house they go
to the house to arrest
him however uh what had happened was
that Oscar Slater and his girlfriend had
actually left that very day they had
gone to Liverpool and then they were
going to um get on a ship the Lucitania
as it happens um to go to New
York now because the cops had just
happened to show up on this day that
they had left the police interpreted
this as oh well the crime was in the
papers today and so he's fleeing from
Justice
right and it didn't help that him and
his mistress had booked passage on the
ship under pseudonyms like under Mr and
Ms name so you know what I mean because
of of the [__] at that time you couldn't
really
cuz they were unmarried and all this
other stuff so they thought that was
kind of
suspicious so
basically what happened though so they
found that out and they're like oh oh
goody like he fleed he flees from
Justice he did the diamond broo this
must be our guy right he's kind of like
a gambler and a prostitute's hanging out
with prostitutes they kind of implied
that he was a pimp too but I don't know
if that's the case damn you just
associate with a with a with with a gly
woman and all of a sudden they make you
a pimp that's what I mean I was like
that's kind of shitty damn me and Jen
are in the trade I'm not a pimp yeah I
mean should have well I'm not [__]
random people for money either we only
[__] each other you know that's
completely different situation yeah but
I mean well obviously he knew she was a
prostitute but I don't think he was
pimping around I think she'd been a
prostitute prior to that she probably
just freelance that's what I mean bring
all the money baby you know some dudes
don't care yeah like I said I I kind of
feel like she'd been doing that before
and he knew about it so and I guess it
didn't bother him they're like hey you
got to make money somehow yeah we know
people like that sure yeah you know the
dude just like go get that money go get
the money girl you hey man to each his
own you know that's what I mean hey but
they got feminist saying that's women's
Liberation it's get the patriarchy I I
don't see how it is but I think it's I
think it's cope but woman's woman can
use whatever means she wants to make
some money as long as she said as long
as she agrees to and it isn't being
forced I don't understand it's crazy
it's actually against with it it's
actually against American tradition to
to to Outlaw prostitution it was it was
legal in Most states up until relatively
recently 1900s yeah it's when it and
like I said I've argued that it's a lot
safer when it's legalized yeah they can
go to the cops if they ever have trouble
yeah you know yeah because if it's
illegal you can't you can't really go to
because you're going to get in trouble
yeah although no if it's a serious
offense if he did something serious to
you go to the if you're a woman of the
trade a dude beats on you and steals
your money go to the cops yeah cuz he
committed a felon what you're doing is
just a
misdemeanor yeah you know say yeah
that's what I was doing I was working
and that's what he did yeah you know
it'll help them catch him because he's
doing it to other girls yeah
yeah so yeah so the okay so I feel like
they kind of decided this was their dude
like right from the jump
right here is the one tiny tiny little
problem though and the cops absolutely
knew about this before all of the [__]
that I'm going to talk about
happened you know the diamond brooch
that was started this whole thing that
you know Oscars Slater supposedly pawned
yeah it was not the same Diamond brooch
at all it didn't look anything like the
one that was stolen from Mar and
gilchrist's
flat and not only that but Oscar Slater
had pawned this
brooch way back in
November of 1908 more than a month
before the murder took place so it was
as far as I am aware it was actually a
brooch that he had that it either
belonged to him or belonged to his uh
girlfriend and whenever he needed extra
money he would go pawn it and then get
it back you know what I mean so he had
actually pwned he had the ticket he had
pwned it like more than a month before
the murder and it was wasn't even the
same roach anyway so obviously that
whole cuz this was that was the whole
clue that like LED them to him in the
first place and that was like [__]
obviously and the cops absolutely knew
that it wasn't the same
brooch but they didn't seem to give a
[__] to be honest uh they had decided
that Oscar Slater was the murderer and
godamn it they were going to go [__]
get
him uh problem was though they had
already sailed for New York on the
Lucitania so what they did was they sent
a cable to the New York
police so by the time the ship got to
New York on January 3rd they arrested
Oscar Slater like right off the
ship and they put him in this um kind of
holding prison thing called the tombs
like on man in
Manhattan now meanwhile back in Glasgow
the newspapers over there printed Oscar
's name and picture in the paper and
said what he that he had been arrested
for a Mary and Gilchrist murder which
was like a big deal you know what I mean
like this old lady like being [__]
brutally beaten to death right so
they're like here's the guy we got him
he was in New York like it was this big
exciting thing we went all the way
across the Atlantic like to catch him
you know what I
mean so at this point you know he's in
New York now and you know the cops have
follow like the New York cops caught him
but at this point they have to do
extradition
right another thing they did and this
was [__] crazy to me they actually
you know the three witnesses that had
seen the guy who was um Arthur Adams the
neighbor um uh Helen lamby the maid and
Mary Baran the 14-year-old girl the
police in Scotland sent the three of
them on a ship over to New York to
identify Oscar Slater over there in case
it took a long time to get him
extradited I'm assuming which is crazy
so they sent the three of them over
there like on a [__] ship across the
Atlantic and one thing that they did
too was that they kind of the cops seem
to
have finessed all of their descriptions
because like I said their descriptions
of the dude that they saw were kind of
different so they kind of finessed them
until they all kind of sounded the same
also they put probably deliberately the
they put um Mary uh banin Baran rather
um and Helen lambi in the same cabin and
the J the ship Journey was like 12 days
so they put them in the same cabin
presumably so they could like get their
story straight like you know match up or
whatever I kind of think that that's
probably what they told
them so the three of them and some of
the cops from Scotland get to New
York now they see Oscar Slater In the
Hall of the courthouse like with
handcuffs on now Helen and Mary said
yeah that's totally him but Arthur Adams
the neighbor was like not sure he's like
is that him he's like I don't think that
was the dude that I saw he wasn't like
super
sure now Oscar Slater was obliged
because he'd been arrested to get a
lawyer um so he got an American lawyer
now this lawyer said I think that you
should resist the extradition like try
to fight it
but Oscar Slater I'm not entirely sure
why he said no I'm innocent I'll go back
voluntarily and we'll get this all
sorted out he's going to go back to
Scotland to clear his name I don't know
if it was just naev on his part yeah he
probably thought [__] the justice
system actually had justice in it no
it's a game but you're going to a
[__] crap Sho right yeah so he was
just like well obviously I didn't do it
so it's like so I'll just go back and
face them and they'll see that I didn't
do it that's what every innocent
[__] in in prison doing time was
thought Oh They'll figured this out they
they're smart guys they'll figure out
that I didn't do it
wrong no yeah this ended up biting him
in the ass spoiler
alert I don't blame him because like I
said considering again spoiler alert
that Oscar Slater like pretty much
99.99% could not have committed this
murder um so he's just all he knows is
he's on a ship with his girlfriend he's
going to New York he shows him in New
York and he gets arrested he doesn't
know who the [__] that woman is he
doesn't know what the [__] is going on
and he's just like he gets arrested out
of the like from his point of view so
he's just like well obviously I didn't
do the [__] so it's like this can't be
right they're going to figure this out
so even though the lawyer told them well
you should fight the extradition like
you know make them like not take you
back to Scotland he's like no I'll go he
he volunt he volunteered to go back to
Scotland because he thought they were
going to sort it out I was like man no
poor bastard yeah um yeah it didn't work
out quite like that no usually what
happens is is that who's ever arrested
or accused is found guilty doesn't
matter if they're guilty or not just by
chance though because the police and
circumstances and the way the guy's
arrested they tend to arrest or and
accuse the guy that is guilty so that's
kind of an accurate way to do it but if
you arrest the wrong guy and you get him
into a courthouse you convict him too we
there's certain States and especially
Southern States well even California
they have like 90s something 95%
conviction rate just anybody who comes
comes in front of them is found guilty
yeah because that's kind of it's kind of
a shitty aspect of the justice system is
that if you get arrested of something
for something I kind of feel like the
majority of the public are like oh well
if he got arrested there must be
something to it yeah right cuz they
wouldn't have just arrested him for
nothing I'm like no they do sometimes
yeah and then put it before a jury so he
looks guilty like from the beginning
which is definitely what happened in
this situation and if you see what a
jury looks like a lot of times
especially for like criminal a criminal
justice type jury these just people that
just drafted from the local area average
IQ is probably like 90 so they're not
[__] real intelligent you know and
uh the defense and the prosecutions
happening at a college level they don't
they can't tell what's true and what
what's a truth and what's a lie they
can't they're not intelligent enough to
go through the
evidence um so they tend to just convict
the guy or set set him free based upon
emotions just how the Dude Looks what
color he is just everything well that
was definitely a factor in this case too
which we'll get into a little bit Yeah
but it does seem like because like I
said the whole reason that Oscar Slater
was on the cops radar was because this
dude who he kind of knew that was in a
gambling Club said oh this guy had a
pawn ticket for a diamond brooch and
they go to his house
then they find out the police found out
before they even went to New York to
extradite him that that wasn't the same
brooch and he haded it like a month
before the murder anyway so it obviously
wasn't the one that was taken from the
flat but they were just like bound and
determined they were like oh well this
our guy anyway we don't give a [__]
about that you know what I mean so
crazy
so so basically there he's in the um the
tombs he's in Manhattan
still and he wrote some letters to his
friends which I guess guess still
survive um and he's just like completely
bewildered by the whole situation as you
would be and they're like he didn't even
know they said he didn't even really
know like what date the murder took
place like when he wrote letters to his
friends he thought it took place like on
a different day and [__] like that so
that just goes to show like
how much he didn't know about talking
about this something just dawned on me
what's
that I bet you AI would have a more
accurate is it would be have a better
chance of f of coming up with a verdict
than the average
umur the average ID jury sure yeah I bet
you if you did a if you let AI do it
you'd probably get much better
results and I bet you the AI is at a at
a point where it could do it they say's
really good at making legal rits real
good at law I mean you could I I I would
feel better if it had like a human
backup like somebody to kind of look
over and like CH do you want a human Tri
do you want a human yeah that might work
do you want humans to try do you want AI
to do it if I was innocent I'd say AI
cuz there's no emotions involved in that
yeah cuz going just by the
testimon just by the evidence yeah bet
AI be much better at it cuz holy [__] if
I got accused of some random crime and
and I got a jury with like a bunch of I
don't know yeah like super conservative
Christians or something like that they
would fry my ass yeah it could be
anything just people that hate you yeah
uming you know just basically you're
being tried by a Lynch Mob yeah um but
that's what the deal was that old
classic science fiction movie The Day
the Earth Stood Still Remember When the
damn uh aliens showed up at out inside
the White House out outside Congress
Gort came out and he said we've given
over all control of our society to these
superhuman robots Gort is one of them
yeah and he's going to pass judgment on
you all destroy your planet if you don't
change your
ways yeah it might be better to let AI
handle a lot of that [__] I know people
are scared of that I'm like I don't know
let's give them let's give it a shot
probably be a lot better than humans
well you could test humans kind of suck
you could test it you could test it you
could test it just with uh real cases
and see see what the AI says yeah and
it's and then cases that were overturned
based on new evidence come see see if
the AI predicted that the guy was
innocent right I'd do [__] like that
yeah like I'd probably take my chances
with that rather than people yeah I'd
rather have ai [__] judge me I
probably would too to be honest with you
cuz there' be no emotion cuz I I've met
law I've met humans and uh we're we're
not all that cool they're
fallible yeah humans just go by feelings
mostly feels instincts and what their
intuitions are a lot of times they're
wrong A lot of times they're wrong
yeah that's why it's kind of always
better to be a little bit circumspect
don't go with your first [__] gut
instinct and don't go with what you feel
and all that other kind of [__] dep on
situation because well see in a dark
alley follow your [__] gut like [__]
like that sure but I'm just saying for
stuff that takes a little bit more
thought behind it cuz humans are real
good at having a a knee-jerk emotional
reaction to something and then coming up
with some intellectual justification for
it after the fact that's pretty much how
most human brains work we can't help it
that's just the way they work so you
have to kind of be aware of that yeah
you know what I A lot of times the
smarter a person thinks they are the
Dumber they are I just watched this
thing where they had these uh six
college students try to rate one another
on the IQ scale and the girl who had the
PHD who thought she was the smartest one
was at the bottom she only had 110 IQ
and then the ex-military guy who was
ex-marine who she thought was a dumbass
was 136 so he had higher IQ than her she
boy she was [__] saying all kinds of
cope but that was like on on YouTube you
could see that like predicting IQ and
just search that they show you that
intelligence and people's people's
judgments of others tend to be
inaccurate well well and the thing about
IQ tests too is that they're not super
they're very limited it really only
tests one or two types of intelligence
and there's lots of different kinds I'm
not sure I'm not sure about that some of
that I think might be Co there's
different types of of there's different
types of intelligence yeah but like I
said the test by their by their nature
only test particular yeah IQ tests about
it's about problem solving solving
puzzles that's all it is but solving
puzzles is important
it is yeah I'm not saying that I'm just
saying that there are different types of
intelligence that some tests don't
measure that's all I'm saying um okay so
where was I so yeah so this poor guy is
just like completely befuddled by this
whole situation like I said as you
probably would be because this is
horrifying so the cops are like asking
he's like look I never met this woman
I've never been to her house I don't
know her from Adam and they were like
well what's with all of these aliases
that you go under like why does the door
on your house say say Anderson dentist
when that's not your [__] name and
he's like okay well I'm going to tell
you he's like when I first moved to
Glasgow you know I met this woman the
Scottish woman and I married her like I
said he had been married before like I
said he was actually still married
technically um but you know after a
little while we were only married for a
little while she was a drunk she kept
spending all my money and stuff like
that so I left but we didn't get
divorced so I basically just kind of
kept changing names every now and then
so she wouldn't find me and like look
for money that's basically what he said
and he's like and I started doing that
too like after he met his mistress who
they were together for a long time uh
the French lady and um so he's like we
were just kind of trying to stay off her
radar you know what I mean that's
basically all he was
doing now here's the thing so Oscar
Slater and we'll get into this too where
you were saying about uh what people
look like their race and everything like
that because that was absolutely a
factor in this because Oscar
Slater was a German
Jew not only that um he was
very foreign looking like he looked
Jewish I if there is such a thing I saw
pictures of them I didn't really I
didn't really think that but in the
Glasgow of the time which was pretty ly
white um he stood out like a sore thumb
he just like looked Latin to me and the
thing about it is I mean you know
anti-Semitism is you know very is G very
common throughout history but it was um
pretty bad in Glasgow around this time
period right um especially because there
had been a lot of Jewish
immigration uh starting in the 1880s
into Scotland because they were fleeing
persecution from the Russian Empire
right um and a lot of them kind of lived
in poorer neighborhoods there were also
other immigrants there like from Italy
or Ireland or whatever and so there was
kind of a lot of prejudice against
them
now the thing about it and some people
have noted that one of the witnesses
Mary Baran the 14-year-old girl that
said that she had seen the guy that left
the thing like in the street had
said and I don't know if she used these
exact words but said that he had like a
bit like a big nose or like a hooked
nose like that's kind of how she
described him so you know which
obviously is a very common like Jewish
stereotype like that's how they used to
draw them like in those cartoons and
[__] like that how North Koreans draw
all white people that's H is that funny
in North Korean anti-us propaganda they
all draw all draw they draw all white
guys with that nose isn't that funny
yeah because we got all kind of
noses youed should hear some of those
defectors [__] some of those Defector
girls [__] they got one I forgot her
name yoen Park they all you I don't
remember what her name is but she's
married to to an American guy now but
she's the first time she saw an american
guy she was [__] super
impressed because they weren't like they
were drawn you know well yeah we don't
look like she expected a Monster
yeah that's it that's funny but yet at
the same time it's like really sad yeah
it's really sad because if you grew up
in a really closed in society like that
and that's all you knew of the outside
world yeah she like oh that
motherfucker's cute he was
[Laughter]
jacked yeah I mean there's okay looking
people all over the world it's
fine we don't look like Monsters yeah
mixtape Swagger says one of my favorite
shows on YouTube a oh thank you very
much no another show that's why that's
why he's commenting on this one go get a
drink need more ice uh yeah my ice kind
of melted I'm stilling my first drink
but my ice kind of melted I'm hoping the
alcohol will make this cold kind of
subside a little bit I don't know I
guess it's a cold we both have it's not
bad but I just feel a little weird
that's all but
yeah um yeah
so no one's entirely sure like how much
anti-Semitism played into the cops going
after Oscar Slater but I'm pretty sure
it was a factor um
because one you know because he was
quote unquote foreign looking and he
stood out um two he was kind of a little
bit of a petty criminal already he was a
gambler and stuff like that hung out
with prostitutes so you know it not
really looking too good for him right
it's just seems like he's not going to
get a fair shake at all I will note also
that after Slater was
arrested um the remainder of the Jewish
community in Glasgow which I believe at
that stage was just like a few thousand
people maybe like 4,000 people something
like that um they didn't really want to
come to his defense which is kind of
shitty but I can also understand because
they didn't want to be seen as it's like
they were dealing with their own [__] um
at the time and they're like look if we
look like we're standing up to like
defend a possible murderer then the
target's going to be on our backs too so
they didn't really want to do that which
like I said is kind of shitty but I
understand where they were coming from
you know what I
mean so Oscar Slater as I said
voluntarily went back to
Scotland um because he was just going to
clear his name you know what I mean
which like I said
seems just seems so sadly optimistic and
that just I don't know that was just
really makes me
sad so he goes back and there you know
the cops were making a big deal of you
know oh we showed up at your house and
you had just left that day like you know
got on the ship and like went to New
York almost like you were fleeing from
Justice and he said no no it's like this
trip has been planned since the
beginning of December he's like I've
written a lot of letters to my friends
saying yeah I was going to take this
ship to New York I think he was going to
San Francisco ultimately like to open up
a gambling Club out there or something
like that so he had been planning it for
quite a while and had bought tickets in
advance but of course the cops didn't
really give a [__] about that
either um he also had an alibi for the
night of the
murder um he actually was at he was seen
at a like a Billiards
Club um earlier the in the
evening and his friend said he left
about 6:30 uh which is about half an
hourish like before Mary and gilr was
killed but at that point like he went
home he had dinner with his girlfriend
and uh his girlfriend maid whose name
was Catherine schaltz um he was in the
house until about 8:00 he went out into
the alley behind the house to smoke
where his uh neighbor who was a grer
that knew him saw him so he was
obviously there then um and he was also
seen at another club like a gambling
club like later on that night so he
seemed like he was at home or just in
his own little area all of that night
and a lot of people saw him and so it's
unlikely that he had been at Mary and
gilr house at any
point so they put him in a lineup or an
identity parade as they would say over
there and um they they did have several
witnesses that came forward saying that
they had seen him uh around that area of
Mary and giler's house on the night of
the murder however it should be noted
that all of these witnesses that they
brought in only came forward after Oscar
Slater's picture had been in the
newspaper which seems a little
prejudicial and it should be noted too
that the other people in the
lineup uh which were I believe there
were 11 other people in the lineup nine
of them were cops uh two of them were
Railway officials all of whom were white
Scottish people so they didn't have any
Jewish competition up there they didn't
have any other foreign looking dudes he
was only one so he's standing there like
hey yeah you could put another Jewish
guy I'm the Jew you know put another Jew
in there and they would have picked him
which they would not do that nowadays
they would not do that no they put
people have similar descriptions yeah
because they want to make goddamn sure
that it's like you're picking it is yeah
so they're not going to put like 11
super white dudes and one quote unquote
for [__] might as well put 11 Chinese
guys there that's what I mean that's
what I'm saying so the fact that they
did it
and I'm just going to say and all these
people are long dead so it's fine those
cops knew exactly what they were doing
it seemed like to me they just wanted
either that or they just didn't give a
[__] or trying to get through the thing
as fast as they could yeah I mean I'll
get into like some theories about this
later on I'm not usually a big
conspiracy theorist but I do think there
might have been something going on here
uh why they railroaded this particular
that was him this is him so we're going
to take him he's a bad guy anyway
hanging out with women of repute we're
going to put lock him up where he
belongs yeah yeah he totally did it yeah
so I don't know but like I
said so uh so yeah so obviously he gets
picked out like I said not only had his
picture been in the paper so everybody
he already saw him uh you know everybody
was already primed to think of him as
the murderer but then they put him in a
lineup with 11 white dudes or whiter
dudes I guess he's still a white
guy so he goes to trial
now at his
trial which uh the judge's name was Lord
Charles John
Guthrie uh the
judge even from the beginning of the
trial really did not seem to um make any
uh play toward being impartial in the
slightest uh most of the [__] that he
said because I believe all the trial
because I've read like um you know bits
of the trial transcript and most it is
on the internet as far as I
know and uh just the [__] that he said
was just basically like yeah the dude's
guilty we're we're going to find the
dude guilty it was like he just didn't
really seem to be like trying to
sugarcoat it at
all now so the prosecution's case their
entire case hinged
on witness uh you know eyewitness
testimony now they brought up Arthur
Adam who was the neighbor you know he
was the first guy that was
there and they asked him was Oscar
Slater the guy you saw walking out of
the
flat and Arthur Adams still was not sure
he didn't say no but he didn't say I
think what he said it was something like
and this is an exact quote but he said
something to the effect of well I it
wasn't unlike him he said something like
that so he couldn't bring himself to say
yeah that was the dude but he also
couldn't bring himself to say no that
absolutely wasn't the dude you know what
I mean mhm like he wasn't real
sure but then they brought up Helen
lamby the maid and Mary Baran the
14-year-old girl and they like yeah that
that's totally him you know what I mean
which like I said but they had also kind
of gotten their stories together on that
Journey over the [__] Atlantic so
there was that
too um and again the prosecution hit
very hard on that whole oh you know
Oscar Slater took off with his Miss and
they had went under pseudonyms like they
were married and it was the same day
that all the [__] came out in the papers
so it was a flight from Justice um even
though it had at this stage I Believe
been proven that the um that his journey
that his ship Journey had been booked
like at the beginning of December so
they had been planning this trip for
several weeks at this
point now the defense came up and they
had all of these witnesses that gave
Oscar Slater a alibi an alibi for the
night of murder um and they also had
people come up and say no he had plan
this journey like a long time ago it
wasn't a flight from Justice you know
him and his girlfriend have been
planning to make this journey for like
weeks we heard about it at the beginning
of December like you know three weeks
before the murder
happened I will note too that there was
a big to-do made about this little
Hammer that was found in like among
Oscar's
possessions and the prose uors tried to
imply that this was the murder
weapon even though and I believe they
even he even said this a trial even the
forensic examiner
whatever said that that hammer was way
too small to have inflicted the wounds
that they saw on Mary and gilr's head
they're like there's no way it would
have had to be twice that size at least
because of the damage that was done cuz
it was a little bitty hammer and he
actually said um or rather his
girlfriend said he's like well that's
just the hammer he used to like break
coal like for the fire it's just like a
little bitty it was a little bitty
Hammer but they tried to like make out
that that was the murder weapon because
they found it in [__] or whatever um and
as I mentioned before the medical
examiner the doctor that had come there
at the scene he thought that the murder
had been carried out by the chair
because that's what had the blood all
over
it now I should note too that Oscar's
defense
team um advised him not only not to take
the stand in his own defense but also
not to talk during the whole trial
because they thought that because he had
a thick German accent that it would bias
the jury against him which as it turned
out um they didn't have to worry about
that because the jury was already
prejudiced against him so it didn't
matter if he talked or not evidently it
might have helped if he had taken the
stand in his own defense I'm not
entirely sure I mean hindsight's
2020 now
so the it's crazy to me because when you
read through the trial
transcripts pretty much the defense
counters every single prosecution thing
it's like look that wasn't the brooch um
you know we have the pawn ticket it was
completely different it was pwned at a
completely different time it's like look
he booked this trip that you said was a
flight from Justice like 3 weeks before
the murder everybody knew about it it
was he wasn't fleeing from anything it
was already planned um you know he has
this Alibi all these people saw him like
at this club or at this house or
whatever it's like at the time of the
murder so it's like there's no way you
could have done
it but still the judge who seems to have
decided prior to the festivity starting
that this dude was guilty no matter what
he basically said that Oscar Slater had
poor
character and this is a direct quote
from the judge he said he's maintained
himself by the ruin of men and on the
ruin of women oh [__] living for years
past in a way that many black guards
would scorn to live the many the many's
life has been not only a lie for years
but is so today we do not know whether
he ever did an honest day's work in his
life so like I said little bit um
prejudicial
yeah the judge even stated outright that
a quote man of that
type um which is kind of like the you
people of back then was not entitled to
a presumption of innocence yeah that's
some hardcore [__] now now I watched the
do guilty until you prove him inent
that's what that I watched a documentary
about I mean that is an extraordinary
statement for a judge to make and like I
was watching this documentary and said
that no as far as they know it's like no
Scottish judge has said anything like
that before or since that is a crazy
that gets you dispar in the US a man of
that type does not have the presumption
of innocence yeah that would get you
disbarred in the US he just said that
yeah yeah holy crap I could not believe
that like when I read I'm like that is
[__] that is out of line right there
your license needs to be revoked when
you say that [__] and the shitty thing
is that I don't think the Judge got in
trouble for this even though he
absolutely should have oh yeah it's got
to be a [__] Fair in in
impartial [__] court system I mean he
had just decided just the facts man I
don't know I don't know if the judge
just was like I don't like this
[__] because he's a Jew and a
German and he's like hangs out with
hookers yeah and he just decided man
[__] this guy in the in the US that' get
overturned by the Supreme Court it'
probably take [__] 10 years to get up
to the Supreme Court but I don't even
think Supreme Court some of the some of
the uh the higher courts of the state
that you're in would go I you can't say
that in front of a jury they they'd
demand a retrial probably well that's
what like I said I watched the
documentary that one of the
documentaries that I watched was a
Scottish documentary yeah and they were
talking about this and they said that is
they like they couldn't believe it
themselves it's like it's like no judge
prior to that had ever said that and no
judge after that has said anything like
that he's tripping they're like because
they're like you know Scotland takes
great pride in the fairness of its legal
system and it's like for somebody to say
something like that outright is just
completely outrageous idea of most of
the idea of the law in most of the
states inside our Union all of them
except one are based on British common
law so it was the idea of at least
having a fair and impartial jury and
having a fair judge somebody who's you
know neutral about the that's a British
thing you know and that went on to
Scotland you know Ireland it's a good
idea yeah now whether or not that
actually happens in real life well
juries it's easy to [__] turn juries
against people yeah kind of dumb you
know people are fallible like you said
so it doesn't work out that good in
practice at least you got to go through
the damn but you know but like I said
it's good idea one is supposed to say
some [__] like that yeah yeah but that's
why it's so shock well that's why
everybody after after the jury finds you
guilty at sentencing he can say all
kinds of [__] to you yeah because they
go well technically now you're guilty so
I can say whatever I want about right
he's already found this dude guilty yeah
and like I said just from Reading just
skimming through the transcripts of the
trial it was pretty clear that the judge
already thought the dude was guilty like
from the second he walked into the room
and he said statements that he made like
were pretty were pretty obvious about
how how he felt about that and now the
one state that is not based on British
common law is Louisiana based on French
Napoleonic law you're guilty and to
proven
innocent there but that just lock them
up Louisiana Yeah Yeah well
yeah [__] up place it is kind of [__]
up yeah live there [__] if you're
accused there you're
guilty yeah and I really do like and
like I said this doesn't always work out
in practice either but technically
you're not really supposed to be able to
use
prior
convictions against the per like on this
conviction unless I mean you can argue
that it's like oh well if it's like a
murder or something it's like oh this
dude was like a convicted killer from
before like yeah you can use that but
like other crimes like petty [__]
technically you're not really supposed
to think even in Louisiana they can't do
that no they can during sentencing phase
you've been found guilty this now how
you got found two three other ones you
know I think during yeah I think most
States like I said I'm not sure about
all the intricacies of all states laws
but I think most of the time yeah during
the sentencing phase I think you can but
during the conviction phase I don't
think you're allowed to introduce but
like I said you can but you know usually
the other team will bring in like an
objection or you know it be like hey
strike that from the record orever a lot
of States you could if you get the
defendant on the
stand the the prosecution can ask you
the defendant have you ever been found
guilty of a crime before right in some
states I think they can do
that uh I that and I don't know if
that's 100% true but I think they can
sometimes which that's pre they they'll
use you to prej Prejudice the jury
against you yeah well and that's kind of
that's kind of like another one of those
gray areas because if somebody like okay
for example if somebody's being accused
of
murder yes it is relevant if they'd been
convicted of murders before obviously so
you know to an extent yes that should be
able to be introduced because that's
relevant but if you've been accused of
some other [__] like well like in this
case where he was accused of Mur even
though like he didn't do it and they're
bringing up all this other stuff like
his gambling [__] and like the
prostitution which he I don't even think
he'd been convicted of anything like
that I think the only arrests that he'd
ever had were for like well I think he
had an assault charge and he was
acquitted so I don't think he'd actually
yeah so I don't even think he'd been
convicted of anything so the fact that
they were just bringing this up as
though he was just some scumbag yeah um
that's extremely prejudicial and would
not normally be allowed and I don't even
think back then this would have been
allowed in Scotland yeah in the US
2023 a guy of this background would go
unnoticed he'd be unnoticed
basically that what he got into a
fight yeah I mean that seems to out with
a girl who and like I said he didn't
even get
convicted he got acquitted he got
acquitted of it okay he accused of being
in and it wasn't even in Glasgow it was
in London he hangs out with a chick who
might be turning tricks yeah allegedly
yeah that's not even like I said even if
she was so what yeah that's nothing no
that's what I'm saying that's not and
this guy said he never done a good work
day that's not beating an old woman to
death yeah yeah those are two completely
different things yeah you know I think
he was just a street player yeah I mean
it seems to be that that's all he was he
was just kind of like a hustler yeah you
know what I mean he was out there
gambling he's just trying you know his
girlfriend was money allegedly turning
tricks whatever they're just trying try
to make money you know what I mean like
I said trying to live the life things
are tough all over right got to make
money doesn't trying to live a little
bit on Easy Street doesn't seem like he
was really hurting anybody as far as
anybody knows yeah there were a lot of
these guys in the US well yeah and there
were a lot of them over there too yeah
so it's like so I I kind of feel like
the fact that they just had it we just
gunning for this dude like I said I
think a large part of it too was the
fact that he was a German Jew um you
know in in Scotland particularly at this
time period really did not like Jewish
people and they really did not like
Germans uh so the fact that there were
two that he was two of those things uh
probably did not help at all I don't
really uh I don't really blame the
street Hustlers of this [__] era I
don't either because legitimate jobs of
their class in other words the kind of
jobs that guys like this would get
[__] drudgery man you get killed
doing them sure and they didn't pay you
[__] I don't blame anybody for trying to
like [__] yeah he'd probably want to
get some multitude of side hustles sure
which is the internet version of what me
and Jen do yeah we're doing all bu
little hustles yeah you know making
products and [__] doing shows and
[__] of different kinds you know and you
got to have multiple income streams
because you never really can live just
on one of them you got you need all of
them he's just doing the same thing we
kind of did but he's doing it on the
street yeah yeah well that's kind of how
I saw it like I said he doesn't really
seem to have hurt anybody that I know of
he's just playing his and what what he's
talking about is entertainment right
it's gambling yeah yeah mostly gambling
it was just entertainment
yeah
so so after the judge made all of these
extraordinary statements about how a man
of that type is not entitled to a
presumption of innocence which like I
said is a crazy [__] statement for a
judge to make um the jury comes back it
only took them an hour and 10
minutes and they came back with a guilty
verdict now I should note I'm not sure
about if anybody um knows anything about
Scottish law nowadays you can tell me um
it might still be the same but in this
time period you didn't have to have
um uh a unanimous decision because in
the US it everybody has to agree no no
well depends on the state it depends and
on a death penalty case they usually
have to agree and the other ones they
could be there could be hung juries
there could be uh well yeah I know
that's well that's what I mean if they
don't all agree it's usually like a hung
jur and they usually have to do the [__]
over again or you can yeah they can they
say do a retrial we got to retrial but
usually they don't want to retrial it so
what they do is they come at the defend
it with a [__] plea it's like we
don't want to try this over again but if
you plea guilty to this you only have to
do [__] nine months you'll be good to
go [__] like that you know what I mean
nine months instead of 10 years just be
guilty to it but the thing about
Scotland too is that you didn't have to
have a unanimous decision it just had to
be a majority another thing that
Scotland did that we don't do here but
maybe we should because I always thought
this was kind of a good idea is that
they not only had guilty and not guilty
they also have one in between called not
proven which is like you don't
necessarily think the dude didn't do it
but you're not entirely sure that he did
do it either ver that's what I mean so I
think that's good that they have that in
between that's a not sure we're not sure
yeah we're not sure right yeah so they
have that so they have like three
options yeah which is good because you
shit's not black and white and I don't
think like the jury's be like well maybe
he did it but I'm not entirely certain
like I I I'm not sure enough to like
send the dude to The Gallows or whatever
so I'm just going to say not proven
maybe he did end up being what's called
a responsive verdict in other words a
verdict that's not quite fullblown okay
it's not really sure so instead of
giving the guy a life sentence we're
going to give him five years that [__]
like that yeah but how it shook out the
jury came
back and the uh how they voted voted
nine of them voted guilty five of them
voted not proven and one voted not
guilty which to me it should have been a
lot more not guilty because it was very
very obvious at least by today's
standards that the dude Li really did
not do it but you know but because the
majority said
guilty um you know he was guilty so the
judge puts on his little black cap and
sentenced him to death damn and uh yeah
so his execution date was set for May
27th uh
1909 um Oscar
Slater when the verdict was read was
obviously beside himself yeah um he
believed a lie he thought he thought the
system was gonna find you know get down
to the truth yeah no that's not how that
happened no you you're you're entering
basically a liveaction game show
I would honestly I'd probably just be
like what country doesn't have
extradition I'm going to run to that
country before I'm not going to get my
no they got you custody now you can't go
anywhere holy crap I would try to escape
yeah but yeah um but yeah so he
apparently like jumped out his chair and
said I came on my own account to the
country because he made a big deal about
it's like hey I came back here
voluntarily like to clear my name or
whatever and you guys [__] I came
over to defend my right I know nothing
about the affair you are convicting an
innocent man yeah they want to hear that
which yeah yeah although I will note
that I guess there was something about
because I kind of feel like up until the
trial and up until the conviction public
opinion was pretty solidly against him
uh because it seemed like you know the
judge the the jury everything like that
and even the Press prior to the trial
had pretty much already decided what
that this is the dude that did it so the
public was not really on his side but
after he jumped up and just made this
statement and he was obviously like I
said just [__] completely bewildered
that this had happened I think public
opinion started to kind of change more
into his in his favor and they're like
oh [__] maybe he didn't do it you know
what I mean because he seemed really
shocked by the whole thing um so by the
time like not too long after the
conviction um they were actually able to
they started setting up um like stations
on street corners in Glasgow where they
would have you could come over and like
sign a petition like to try to you know
get a retrial or get him released or
whatever and they got pretty easily like
20,000 signatures on
that um so yeah so like they for his
sentence to be commuted now because they
got 20,000 signatures uh Oscars Leader's
lawyer at the time sent this petition to
um the secretary for Scotland and at
this point he had enough of the thing
he's like okay well tell you what we're
not going to let him go or nothing like
that but we'll have him we won't do the
death sentence but we'll commute it to
life in prison life at hard labor which
was probably not much better but you
know what I mean they did this they
decided this two days before he was
supposed to hang they said I will
commute a sentence to like a life
sentence but like I said life sentence
hard labor so great so he gets sent to
peterhead prison and put on hard labor
he's like out there breaking rocks or
whatever the
[__] um and while he was there he's like
writing letters about what he thought
really happened CU like obviously it
wasn't me so I don't really know like
what who killed this lady or whatever
but it wasn't
me now at this point um like I said
there was a lot of kind of influential
people that were sort of like on his
side you know what I mean because they
thought man that dude got done dirty now
there was a guy named William Ruff head
who was a Scottish lawyer and he wrote a
book called the trial of Oscar Slater
and that got published in 1910 like
after like the year after he went to
prison and after this book came
out um I like public opinion started
turning even more like in his favor you
know what I mean like they're like holy
holy [__] like this guy really got
[__] over you know what I
mean and one of the people that read
this book was Sir Arthur Conan Doyle
which zanada asked earlier like who that
was that's the dude that he's online
well he did like wait a long time ago
okay I didn't know you were here z um
yeah so I don't know if he still is but
that was a long time Sir Arthur K Doyle
wrote the Sherlock Holmes books uh if
you don't know and he was a hugely
famous hugely wealthy and hugely
influential uh person uh in the UK at
this time so he read this book and he
got interested in this case because Sir
Arthur conand Doyle was very interested
in uh miscarriages of justice and
actually intervened in a lot of cases uh
of of
same now he got so interested that in
1912 he actually published his own book
about the case which is called the case
of Oscar
Slater and in his book he actually um he
thought that Oscar Slater should get a
full pardon because he was obviously not
um
guilty Doyle also came up with a theory
that is kind of more along the lines of
what people think happen nowadays he
thought that whoever killed Mary and
Gilchrist wasn't looking for valuables
it wasn't a robbery obviously because
all of her jewelry that was just laying
around was still there um he thought
that whoever broke in was one somebody
she knew and two that they were looking
for a particular document which was in
that wooden box maybe a will or
something like that um now so all of
this you know stuff that was coming out
all these books and stuff like that um
um ended up reaching the ears of
detective John trench now John trench
had worked on the case originally um you
know he was one of the first ones there
like when Mari and Gilchrist got killed
and everything like
that now he said a bit later on like
after Oscar's Slater had already been
sent to
prison he said that Helen lambi the maid
had actually named the person that she
saw Le leaving the flat she knew who it
was she had said his
name and it was not Oscar Slater
obviously but the thing about it was
that it seems that once the cops found
out about that whole Diamond BR brooch
and all that um they just kind of went
after Oscars Slater and kind of I don't
want to say they forgot about it because
I think they deliberately covered up
covered up the thing sometimes in these
police departments you know what I mean
they want arrest credit and the credit
for solving a
case and they get desperate for it
because they're trying to impress their
boss and their
bosses that they get an innocent guy and
use him too or maybe they convince
themselves that that's the guy because
they're trying to have an admission
mission accomplished kind of feeling and
I think that's kind of well I think
that's an occupational hazard yeah um
among cops investigators stuff like that
it's like you really want to solve a
crime which you know obviously you know
so you might get a suspect that looks
kind of good and say yeah that's him and
you're like yeah and you decide yeah
that's him but like all of this other
evidence starts coming in that says oh
maybe it's not him and you're just like
yep la la la I'm just not going to
listen to that yeah and you just trying
to like I said that's a very human thing
to do and you really really have to
watch and I would hope that more cops
and investigators would be alert to that
proclivity but I don't know if they are
now I have seen some documentaries about
true crime and stuff like that where
cops and investigators are working on
the case they seemed aware of that
prejudice and were trying to like
overcome it you know what I mean because
it's like you know it's very easy to get
sucked into thing like oh my God this is
the guy but then like more [__] comes in
you're like oh maybe it's not the guy no
it totally is the guy you know what I
mean and then you kind of try to push it
into the [__] in a totalitarian
Society what the what the cops do is
they start torturing the guy and it's
they and he goes see I told you he it's
him it's him see he
confessed yeah
that's how they resolve it which like I
said Soviet Union was Notorious for
it yeah I mean it happens a lot it's
like hey we solved all the crimes solve
every [__] crime yeah we don't know
if all the people that are in prison are
the people that did it probably not
confessed you know after we [__] slam
their [__] hand in the damn safe over
and over again sure it was like the
witch trials yeah right yeah it's like
man we stick like hot pokers underneath
your fingernails like you'll [__]
confess toy pretty much anything right
but you know it when we did shows about
the witch trials and medieval torture
and stuff like that people back then at
the time not everybody but there were
people that were aware that it's like
hey um if we torture these people then
they're just going to say whatever we
want to here to get us to stop it people
did know that yeah they were making
money though yeah I just think either
either they didn't care or they thought
they didn't they couldn't do anything
about it or something but I mean some of
the people did seem aware of that look
medieval Europeans and are not not being
[__] racist cuz me and ched are white
all right medieval Europeans [__]
psychos rent with um [__] Rose to the
top oh big In Those Old medieval
societies um they knew that it was a
scam but the whole thing was scam ified
the entire Society was so uh yeah they
didn't care they're like well I got to
look good in order to protect my
position you know here as interrogator
cared about so you know I'm going to
show you what I can do you know I'm the
interrogator everybody you give me I'm
going to tell you I'm going to give you
a confession that's my job another thing
too is there's certain types of people
yeah and particularly types of people
that that want to be in power they want
to be cops or whatever want to run [__]
that they they feel like well I can't
like convict this dude and then go back
on it because that will make me look
weak or wrong and nobody wants to look
like they [__] up right and so they'll
just keep doubling down yeah even though
it's you know even when it becomes even
more obvious that that's not the person
that did it it's like they just keep
digging their heels in and saying
because they don't want to look like
they messed up yeah and In Those Old
societies you had to not only volunteer
for those positions you had to work hard
to get them so only the ruthless were
going to be able to uh get positions of
power not ideal no and uh but here's the
thing we can pretend that we're all high
and mighty our politicians are exactly
the same way [__] if you can lie
cheat and steal you'd make a great
politician that's all they do they're
actors they don't work for you they work
for big corporations and they work for
[__] large conglomerates and
oligarchs that's that's who they're
working for the money doesn't come from
you so uh it's still crooked it's just
crooked in a well like I said yeah and
it probably always will be but it's like
I'll take today over medieval Europe any
[__] day of the week I don't want to
get my toenail pulled out I don't know
about you guys medieval Europe medieval
Europe the average IQ was probably about
80 back then 75 you they weren't they
were
dumb you can tell just by looking at
their artwork they weren't any good at
artwork the Romans were they were a lot
more intelligent on average they
were they had Geniuses and everything
Archimedes some some of those dudes from
they were he was a Greek but he was
involved with the Romans too that dude
had to been a [__] worldclass
Intelligence coming up with the ideas
that he you know mechanical computers
and stuff you know rivaling [__] uh
Albert
Einstein and a lot of the writings
handed down from the Roman Empire they
read just like they were written today
intelligent people yeah I mean I've read
a lot of stuff from back then and in my
Humanities classes and yeah a lot of it
sounds very modern yeah not Medieval
Europe though no not so much not
colonial America either because in high
school I had a whole class about
Colonial American like literature and
stuff and like reading that kind of
stuff yeah it does not sound modern in
the least no they were religious
Fanatics oh yeah big time yeah it's
fascinating to reads basically it's
fascinating to read but woo there's some
crazy [__] in there yeah crazy [__] um
but like the way they thought was crazy
like I get it like intellectually I
understand like why where they got those
ideas from but it's crazy
so okay so John trench who like I said a
detective that worked on the case
originally the murder case originally um
he knew some [__] about the case
including the fact that Helen lambi had
absolutely known the person that she
that she saw leaving the flat and had
named
him um so John trench said like kind of
at the time the other cops were kind of
like hey um why don't you just keep your
mouth shut about it and keep your job
and keep your head down and everything
will be
fine so at the time trench did that but
as the years went on especially after
Oscars later got uh convicted and was
doing hard time in prison he started
feeling a little bit bad about it um so
he decided he was going to do something
about it he's like you know not only is
this poor
man breaking rocks in prison for all of
these years but but also the real killer
is still running around out there
somewhere so he's like okay uh I'm I'm
going to drop my nuts and I'm going to
do something about it so
1914 he goes to a lawyer in Glasgow who
was kind of well known at the time whose
name was Mr cook and he told him what he
knew about the case that had been
suppressed by the police let's call it
that um and he's like what do you think
I should do so Mr cook says um tell you
what I'll go to one of the um Comm the
prison Commissioners in Scotland and
then you know we'll write to some
important people we'll see if we can get
this sorted
out so they basically figured out so
they um went to the Scottish secretary
his name was uh McKinnon wood and they
wrote to him and he wrote them a letter
back and said said to trench it's like
you write up everything you know about
the case and we'll um see if we can do
something about
it so trench he um kind of goes over all
the stuff he writes up this big long
thing and he sends it on um
unfortunately for trench what ended up
happening uh was that he got [__] canned
he got fired um you know what I mean
which is kind of shitty but you know
what I mean he was going against the
cops CU he's like look all of this
information was suppressed the police
supressed all of it because they were
trying to convict Oscar Slater all of
this other stuff that didn't agree with
their narrative they just kind of
covered it up
basically so they were like okay so
we're going to do an
inquiry uh they did established an
inquiry into Oscar slader's
case now the inquiry though kind of left
a lot to be desired let's put it that
way um it was held in
private Oscar Slater um was not invited
neither was his
lawyer um the witnesses were asked to
attend but not required to like they
could show up if they wanted or
not um so the only person that showed up
to this inquiry were uh the sheriff and
the clerk and the witnesses that
bothered to show
up also um there was
no unfettered transcription taken of
this inquiry basically what happened was
that the sheriff gave a summary of what
each witness said
and then if they said something that
didn't agree with the already
established narrative he just kind of
like it out sort of you know what I mean
it was like that kind of thing so not
great now the thing about this one of
the um kind of points of
contention in the initial reports that
Helen lambi had made about recognizing
the dude that came out of Mary and
gilchrist's
apartment now she named him but what
they did in the reports was they kind of
blacked it out and they just called him
quote unquote AB like the initials which
aren't his initials uh who you know who
the guy that she named by the
way now according to
trench after Helen lamby named this
person they went to the dude's house the
day after the murder
happened now trench said I don't I
wasn't there so I don't know what
happened when the pops went to this
dude's
house um he did try to find out but
nobody would tell
him and then he
said that when they came back they were
like oh it wasn't him we've sorted it
out that kind of thing which he thought
was a little
sus also um they went he went and took a
statement from um Miss Burell who was um
Mary and gilr's niece she lived like
down
street now she said that Mary and
Gilchrist didn't get along with any of
her relatives like her family members
and she said that hardly any of her
family members ever came over to visit
her now miss Burell also said that Helen
lambi the maid had come to her house on
the night of the murder which was true
like she went there afterward to tell
her what had happened and Miss Burell
said Helen came to the house and said
she knew who the murderer was I
recognized him she said um and that she
was absolutely sure who it
was O time for another well that's only
oh okay we e mine all right that's
pretty strong I'm going to get another
one all right cuz I know you can't
finish that by the time I show you yeah
probably not I'm getting down to the end
of
it
okay so so yeah so trench said all this
stuff and he's just kind of like he
tells them he's like yeah and then the
cops came back to me and said oh that
dude AB he didn't have anything to do
with the murder it's all fine forget
about it you know what I
mean trench was also pretty sure that
Mary baroman the 14-year-old that said
she'd been in the street and had seen
the dude leaving the apartment that had
like almost bumped into her he was
pretty sure that she had actually not
been in the street at all that day and
he thought that because in the original
reports um there were actually
statements from her boss like the person
she worked for and her sister that Mary
had actually not been there that night
like that she was somewhere
else so he thought that she had made
that story up so there was
that so they asked um Helen lambi and
and uh miss barell about this whole
thing and both of them denied this
story and also uh the other cops in
Glasgow uh pretty much said hey we don't
know what um trench is talking
about and he's just making [__] up or
whatever so this whole inquiry which was
a private inquiry um closed up on on
April
25th and June
17th um Mr wood who was the secretary he
made a statement in the House of Commons
and saying you know there's nothing to
it you know we can't justify like
retrying it or like you know trying to
get Oscars Slater free or anything like
that there's nothing that was
established in this inquiry that would
make us think he was innocent so let's
forget about it so there was
that and Trent
uh as I mentioned at first got suspended
the suspension was on the grounds of
Consulting With a Civilian who in this
case was Mr cook who was the lawyer um
that's what he was suspended for like
about the case and when trench appealed
his suspension he got
canned um now later trench wrote to Mr
wood the lawyer Mr wood had apparently
prior to this said hey if you get in Jam
write me we'll sort this out um so
trench did that he's like hey I got
fired um but Mr wood uh pretty much
ghosted him was like well you're on your
own so you know that's
nice now so the thing about po this poor
guy he did the right thing I mean he
knew something was fishy and he stood up
for the right thing and he got [__]
fired and [__] with now but I mean
later on he did okay later on like he
actually uh well I don't know if he did
okay but he joined the army and going
into World War I um but yeah so the
thing that here's another [__] up
thing that happened both trench and uh
cook later on they got
arrested on they were charged with
reselling stolen jewelry and it all had
to do with this like jewelry store
burglary case that Trent had worked like
trench had worked on like back in 1914 I
think and he's like he obviously hadn't
sold anything like that the the cops
were basically just trying to like Trump
up some charges um because he had pissed
them off I mean it was very very obvious
so him and cook go to trial and the
judge thought the same thing he's like
this is some [__] right here so they
both got acquitted but the fact that the
glasgo cops because trench had made them
mad like they had already fired him but
the fact that they would
bring him up on some [__] charges
that he stole some jewelry and resold it
like from a case that he had worked on
like a Jew which he obviously didn't do
any of that like the fact that they
would try to do that is like really
shitty but [__] they did that they
did though men are [__] you man they
well yeah I told you that's what I mean
I don't understand why women get called
[__] all like men are way bigger
[__] than any woman I've ever met
seriously those are low tea
[__] they become [__] I don't
know but uh I mean both got acquitted
thankfully but um and then trench ended
up going back to the Army uh so he died
in 1918 he died kind of young he died
when he was
50 now interestingly okay so poor Oscar
Slater this whole time is still in
[__] prison breaking
rocks so in 1925 and consider Oscar
Slater got put in prison in 1909 so it's
now
1925 now an inmate who was a friend of
his named William Gordon was getting out
and he actually smuggled a message from
Oscar Slater out of the prison he Oscar
Slater written it on waterproof paper
and William Gordon rolled it up and put
it under his tongue I've heard also put
under his Dentures I'm not entirely sure
which it is but he put in his mouth
anyway and he smuggled it out of the
prison and it was actually a message to
Arthur Conan Doyle now as I mentioned
Arthur conand Doyle had written a book
about the case and was trying to help
him but like in the ensuing years like
other things had come up and he'd I
don't think he'd forgotten about it but
you know what I mean he wasn't working
on it quite as hard so the note
basically said to Arthur Conan Doyle um
please don't forget about me like you
know keep working on the [__] so Arthur
Conan Doyle did eventually get the
message that had been smuggled out of
the
prison so he kind of snapped into action
he started writing all these letters he
like wrote to all of the press and his
friends and you know he knew all these
people in the government and everything
like that so he started writing and
going like um doing public appearances
and talking about it and [__] like that
so he kind of got the public like fired
up about it again so at this point like
you know the movement to free him
started like gaining more uh impetus I
guess now in
1927 um
interestingly if you were sentenced at
least in this time period I'm not sure
about now but in Scotland in this time
period if you were if you had a life
sentence it was pretty customary for
prisoners to be released on parole after
15 years Oscar Slater for whatever
reason had been in there for more than
18 years and they had not let him out
you know what I mean um and didn't give
him a date when he would be let
out so at this point in
1927 um a friend of
trenches um trench had died by this
point but he had a friend who was a
journalist named William Park and he
wrote another book about the case uh and
this one's called the truth about Oscar
Slater uh and the book he dedicated it
to trench and it was like a big deal and
I think this might have been like the
ultimate Catalyst for Oscar Slater
getting um you know reconsidered getting
let
out now the book laid out a different
Theory this was also trench's Theory
about the case of what he thought
happened he thought that obviously it
wasn't Oscar Slater because he didn't
know Mary and gilr from Adam like I said
he thought that it was somebody that she
knew
well he also thought that whoever went
there hadn't intended to kill her he
hadn't gone gone there intending to kill
her because she had been killed with
what they thought was like a weapon of
convenience like a chair or whatever so
it wasn't premeditated so it wasn't
premeditated that's what he thought um
he thought that whoever went there there
had argued with her and then had hit her
with his hand probably and that she fell
and hit her head on the coal box and
then at this point she was still alive
and he's like well [__] if she's still
alive she's going to tell people because
I'll catch a charge so I'm going to have
to kill her yeah so at that point he
picks up the chair and smashes her head
in so he commits a [__]
murder to get out of a battery this is
when a motherfucker's thinking it over
thinking yeah because he would have done
only maybe like a couple months if she
had pressed charges that's what I mean
that's the thing it's like if you're
going to go to if you do that yeah
you're going to prison okay if they
catch you well if she if she says
anything right you might be to make it
up to her right oh sorry I didn't mean
to do that look here's a couple hundred
bucks or you know well she didn't she
didn't need money she was loading yeah
yeah I lost my I lost my cool you know
yeah and maybe and you know know maybe
press Char right so you never know but
it's super dumb like if you murder her
for sure someone's going to you're for
sure you're going to get in trouble for
that although even though this [__] got
away with it but still that was yeah
because they still don't know who yeah
but but I'll tell you what that that's a
rarity usually they catch it yeah yeah
80% of the time they catch it I mean
that's crazy because you didn't plan it
out all right anything that's done at
the spur of the moment you're going to
leave a messy crime scene you're going
to be implicated yeah so you're going to
get it that's why first-degree murder
carries such a heavy penalty if it's
premeditated you have a much greater
chance of getting away with it that's
how intelligence units have been getting
away with it forever you know and
[__] private contractors that do it
for CIA they use professionals usually
from mobs Italian mob Mexican Mob they
know what they're doing yeah they know
they know police investigative
techniques so they know how to get
around all that
yeah and some of these guys that do it I
believe have law enforcement
backgrounds oh I don't doubt it I don't
doubt
it because they know the they know
forensics the best way to get best way
to get away with any of this [__] is
best way to beat a murder charge is to
never be indicted for it in the first
place so you have to know how
indictments happened so know the legal
system and
forensics well and a lot of murderers
would say too it's like if they never
find the body to you that's another
thing Ah that's only but they can still
convict your ass because there have been
a few cases but it's harder to convict
somebody without a body but because
there have but I have there have been a
few cases where if you look at the
history homicides that have happened in
intelligence communities are are
suspected to be involved the
homicide is always kind of logged in as
a
suicide so that's the key somebody jumps
out of a window somebody hangs
themselves somebody shoots themselves in
the head leaves a suicide note and
everything that's usually how it's done
I always wondered like why if you wanted
to bump off a
[__] why don't more people just
like I don't know push somebody down the
stairs or push them off a cliff or
something like that like something looks
like an accident well that's usually how
they do it but it's pros and it's not
one guy it's a team of them right three
or four guys grab somebody and they toss
them out of a [__] window
like don't don't do some [__] where
there's going to be forensic evidence
everywhere like blood and DNA and [__]
like that that's just stupid that's
that's old school [__] nowadays there's
cameras so they would see who's been in
and out of the building it's it's
different now uh recently ones that look
off suspicious that and it's always in
the political
realm killed in
a random attempted robbery dead a night
out in front of their apartment coming
out of their parking lot Things Are kind
of Taken maybe yeah he must maybe they
mugged him who
knows but it's always to keep somebody
from testifying that's usually what it
is yeah well that happens a lot like
honestly if you go to like the Wikipedia
page for like list of Unsolved Parkers I
feel like 80% of those are either mob
hits or Gang Related or is something
where it's like somebody or political
assassinations or somebody that was
testifying against some big criminal and
it's like oh so turned up dead some
place yeah you know what I mean yeah
they got robbed in the middle of the
night dead shot well no usually they're
just shot in their car or something shot
in their car they shot themselves in the
car the weapons right there you know
yeah there's there's a bunch of
different ways but good movie if you
guys want old there's an old um Robert
Redford movie called uh was it three
days of the
Condor about guy who [__] works great
fuckingo long ago back from the 70s and
that's some classic [__] man three days
of the
Condor
yeah Zan is saying The Sopranos that's
how they try to kill Tony made it look
like a botch carjacking yeah yeah see
what if it was me I wouldn't even do
that I would just like I said I would
just like try to push him down some
stairs or off cliff or something that's
not a sure thing though you got to get
somebody to the cliff so there's a bunch
of you know what I mean yeah I know that
Target may not be in the may not be able
to manver Sho in the car Al like that
seems like too dangerous yeah
carjacking carjacking robbery I mean car
jackings and random robberies do happen
all the time so I guess they figure
that's kind of safe but I'm just saying
you push him out in front of a bus or
something I don't know yeah they they I
think nowadays they just tend to hire
Mobsters that guys that H that have a
good history of [__] hijacking cars
look hijack this car make sure that that
person dies and there you go thank you
just $50,000 thank you very much and the
dude who [__] did it doesn't really
know who he did it for
four Zach just showed up said hey y'all
I just got back from directing a
friend's music video oh okay Su Z that's
cool we're glad you're here I figured
you were off at one of the bath houses
man maybe later
yeah it's Wednesday it's our weekend
we're still gonna make a video me and
you Zach we're gonna see GNA be a music
a Gavin Friday music video with lots of
pink balloons pink balloons and [__]
hot tub foam top of the top of the
[__]
bubbles yeah Penthouse of the [__]
hotel spinning bathtub and [__] [__] J's
gonna be the said you never know never
know Jen's gonna be [__] shooting the
whole thing man by video yeah it'll be
good
[Laughter]
yeah um so yeah so that was uh that was
trench's theory that this was somebody
that she knew came in looking for a
specific thing that was was in that
wooden box and went there not meaning to
kill her but after an argument you know
[__] happens and ended up killing her
anyway now in this book um you know
there are liable
laws and so they couldn't name who this
person was this person that in the
police reports uh was known as
AB although um they did find out later
that the person that apparently Helen
lamby the maid said that she saw coming
out of the apartment was Maran
gilchrist's nephew whose name was Dr
Francis charteris I think is how you
pronounce his last
name now this book comes out and a copy
of it gets sent to the Secretary of
State for Scotland who was Sir John
Gilmore at the time and you know the
book was a big hit so like it you got a
lot of play in the media so a lot of
public interest was kind of rekindled in
the case
right now in um October of like the end
of October
1927 um there was a newspaper story in
which Helen
lambi um said that she you know she
admitted that she yeah I actually
recognized the dude that was coming into
the flat but that when I was questioned
by police they kind of finagled me into
saying that I was
wrong and you know tried to make it seem
like she had seen somebody that looked
like Oscar Slader instead like she so
she kind of implied that she'd been gas
lated into seeing someone else because
when she said when she told the police
who she had seen cuz like I said she did
name the person cuz she knew who he was
and like I said who the person she said
she saw was maryan gilr's nephew doc Dr
Francis chartas that's who she said she
saw leaving the apartment but the cops
were all like nah you couldn't have seen
him it must have been this other dude
and like they just kept at her and kept
at her until she was like okay fine like
I saw this other dude what you know what
I mean so it's almost kind of like but
she came out like many years later and
said yeah they kind of forced me to say
this other
thing now um at this point the uh
Secretary of State for Scotland he read
the book he saw Helen Lamb's uh
statement like and he was like okay
something has to be done about this cuz
this poor man has been in prison like
all this [__] time and he's like
obviously he probably didn't do it so he
goes to the House of Commons and this is
a quote this is what he told them he
said Oscar Slater has now completed more
than 18 and a half years of his life
sentence and I felt justified in
deciding to authorize his release on
license which I guess is like peole as
soon as possible Arrangements can be
made so he's like let that [__]
out of
there so Oscar Slater was actually
released Le um I believe like on a
parole type situation um on November
14th um of
1927 now after he was released because
like I said he didn't just want to be
released like on parole like hey I'm
still Oscar's lateer the murderer he
wanted the [__] overturned you know what
I mean so he would be
innocent so after he got out um Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle um kind of like took
up his case again so he sent a letter to
uh all the MPS and he's like we should
really do like a a whole inquiry into
this trial and like figure out what
happened so at this point um the
secretary of state did agree with him
and said okay so they organized like a
whole new inquiry and they were going to
do like uh the Scottish Court of
Criminal appeal I should note that when
Oscar Slater was first convicted um this
changed later on partly because of this
case I believe um when you got a death
sentence you couldn't appeal it like
there was no such thing no that's
ridiculous as far as I know you should
be able to appeal any case but yeah well
like I said this was 1908 um but mostly
because of this case they were like oh
yeah maybe we should do that so that was
actually like established later
on so they did do an appeal uh in the
summer of
1928 so they laid out all the evidence
once again and at this point the court
this time uh found that the judge uh
Lord guth's um statements to the jury
were obviously very prejudicial yeah and
um that should have thrown the case in
day one demanded a retrial yeah that's
what you would think well and that's
what the court said many years later
after this poor man had spent more than
18 years in
prison but um they were like yeah we
need to overturn this or vacate it as
they say over there but yeah they they
overturned it so they finally did
overturn the conviction so he was an
innocent man uh forth with like going
forward um and at this point uh the
secretary of state says to Oscar Slater
um request whatever amount of money you
want like like his
compensation and we'll see what we can
do for you Oscar Slater said I don't
want your money like I don't I don't
want yeah anything um but still they
they gave him money anyway like even
though he said I don't want any
compensation like he was probably mad I
I don't blame him but he said I don't
want nothing from you
[__] but yeah but they did let
him out um but they did send him a
letter and they said they would send him
at at that point um £6,000 which in
today's a lot of money today's money is
um couple uh 250,000 maybe
$600,000 in American money over a half a
million today and how old was he when
they released him again uh he'd have
been uh
50 H now I can't remember I think he was
38 when he went to PR what was he
38 I think he was 38 when he got
arrested late 50s yeah mid to late 50s
[__] man half a million dollars that or
maybe younger yeah I'm not sure yeah
that that that' support you for the rest
of of your life yeah he got the
equivalent of $600,000 American dollar
in today's money if you bought a modest
house you'd have enough left over to
where you I mean that's a lot I I could
live on that for the rest of my life
quite easily yeah well half
600,000 you buy a
$275,000 house which kind a nice one
would be kind of small a house a car and
then you just have to [__] just
cruise on that until Social Security
kicked in
yeah you could do it yeah I could do it
easy yeah I'm used to I'm used to living
on nothing so I got to buy all her
clothes she don't buy clothes I said B
I'm going to get some clothes I'm
[__] got her a whole new wardrobe in
there sheing and [__] she's got clothes
she hasn't even worn yet I gave you some
money for that too yeah yeah she paid
for half of it yeah I did but she she uh
it left her own devices she'll just sit
here and just wear holes into things she
just used to that yeah I don't give a
crap yeah well no yeah like you said I'm
used to it I'm used to it
she's a child of poverty that's what
happens yeah you're like I can't really
justify I got to save money I can't
spend money on sh on [__] like that you
know what I mean that's what happens to
you when you grow up poor I guess so
Tammy said thank goodness Oscar wasn't
executed right it's like that's right
what if they had hanged the dude and
then like it would all just be posist
and' be like be don't be all happy
because they hanged innocent guys they
oh big time yeah a lot of them a lot of
them got killed well have we ever done I
don't think we've ever done a show on um
uh who was that [__] that they
made that movie 10 rings in place about
John uh chrisy yeah um yeah innocent man
got hanged for some of the [__] that
[__] did yeah so England has a a
a mental block when it comes to death
penalty because they had a a bad
experience with it I think mostly in the
1800s they would hang children for
stealing bread that's how brutal the
[__] British were you know what I
mean but we have it here in the US but
the thing is that they're going to kill
you here you did some [__] you got to
really do some bad [__] to get the death
penalty and they have to be sure that
you were the one that did it usually
it's serial killer type
stuff they got you so dead to rights
yeah you did it well I don't know the
British would just kill you for stealing
well I honestly the case um the case
that I was talking about which I think
that was was that was Christy right that
um that that Welsh guy got hanged for I
remember like for doing his wife and kid
even though even though Dr chrisy had
done it um we should do a show about
that because that's that's a horrifying
case but um I kind of talked about it
some because I reviewed the movie 10
rington place which is a
fictionalization of that um it had John
herd in it actually who was an alien but
um you know the guy that the alien burst
out of his chest that guy like he he was
in it but um it's a great movie it's
depressing as [__] but it's good but
it's based on the true story but that
was the case that made them think hey
maybe we shouldn't just be hanging
people willly nilly because they found
out later oh that dude didn't do it yeah
oopsie but yeah so that's kind of why
they stopped doing it yeah you know the
you know I'm [__] busting on the
British there were some American states
in the 1800s that were like that too
they would hang somebody for pretty
minor kind of minor stuff by today's
standard
in the west if you stole a horse You'
you'd be you'd be
hanged um but the thing is is in those
days stealing somebody's horse was a tan
amount to attempted murder because you'd
die without a horse if they left you on
the range with it so it made some
sense
um
still as long as you know that the
person's guil guilty there are there
there are a lot of [__] that you should
have a death penalty for it usually has
something to do with killing another
person on purpose I don't have unjustly
I don't have an issue with it as long as
they know for sure that that is the
[__] person because I don't
think they should be just killing people
on like some flimsy [__] evidence
yeah and and what I and then find it out
later oh he didn't do it yeah yeah well
too late now what I dislike about the
American system about Le uh lethal
injection so they end up spending a lot
of money on those guys it's got to be
and it takes too long to kill them
they're in there [__] 30 years
fighting over it when they know that
that's the dude that did it Jenny
[__] left me here on my own to handle
the show my own all the time go ahead go
ahead go ahead go ahead I'm entertaining
I got to entertain
now let's see who's
there zanada said that The Sopranos
actually Jenny read read this already
what's up Zan how you doing
man I'm just going to sit here just
[__] [__] until she comes
back so drop something in the comment
section go ahead and keep me
going
she's coming back
out y' let's go ahead and take a
break yeah Tammy said there's another
case where they executed a mentally
[__] man yeah I remember that one
there was I think that's the guy that
when he's going off to his ex
execution he asked for his final meal
and they gave him a meal and everything
and he left the cake and they said what
about the cake don't you want to eat eat
that eat that slice of cake and he goes
I'll eat it when I'll eat it after the
execution which that makes me so sad
yeah I'll eat it
after yeah I can't believe you were like
you left me in by myself I'm like yeah
you leave me by in here by myself all
the time yeah you got [__] to read over
there you're doing a show you got a
whole script yeah but I mean rest it's
not a script it's just information that
I refer
to he's good at EXT extemporaneous stuff
though that's
what um yeah we've totally executed and
it's probably more than we'd like to
admit that's
why I'm not a fan like I said there's
you like Cal kid like I'm not sad that
Ted Bundy got [__] fried or nothing
like that because that dude was a piece
of [__] there's some people that are
just people like that are just not
you've revoked your human card you know
what I mean at that point so whatever
they do to you is fine but that's kind
of like a very small percentage most
people that commit just kind of [__]
crimes yeah I I don't think they should
be doing that [__] to
them um yeah and said there's always a
margin of error that's what I mean it's
just like you better be godamn you
better have some [__] DNA you better
have just all of this information all
your [__] ducks in a row to be doing
that that's why I'm not I'm not really
all that bothered
by I don't know by by all the appeals if
you're going to have the death penalty
you like I said you have to be [__]
sure you can't just do some [__] like
like this where it's like this dude
obviously didn't do it and they even
kind of knew at the time I feel like
that he didn't do it and they're just
like he's going to hang and they would
have hanged him probably if all these
people hadn't signed that petition two
days further we're going to hang him
they were like oh yeah maybe we'll just
like commute it to a life sentence cuz
all these people are mad about it and
it's just kind of if that hadn't
happened they'd have hanged him and then
later on they'd have been like oh he was
innocent oh well nothing you can do
about it now dude's dead you know what I
mean so you can't take it back so I I
they really really have to be [__]
sure about that kind of [__] [__]
sure yeah and a lot of states with the
death penalty don't use it much anyway
yeah they they usually don't um which
like I said that's that's good I I don't
have a problem with that like I said
have a problem with
it in principle if it's a really really
horrible person and they're absolutely
[__] sure that they did that [__] but
I don't like this oh maybe they did it
you know what I mean that's not cool
like I said they were going to hang this
dude and obviously he didn't do it which
is crazy and he just like only got out
of that [__] by the skin of his teeth
here's this crazy thing so he gets the
equivalent of $600,000 in American money
in compensation even though he didn't
ask for it they just gave it to him
now it turned out though that he had to
pay for the appeal himself which again
is some [__] I don't know I don't
think they don't do it like that anymore
but they did back then now the cost of
the appeal was 1,500 pounds in those
days money which was what like a quarter
of what he got right so he would had to
pay like a quarter of what he got for
the
appeal also Arthur conand okay so Arthur
conand Doyle I feel like this was like a
little bit shitty Arthur conand Doyle
comes out and he thought that just for
an for Honor purposes I guess that Oscar
Slater should pay back all the people
that had contributed money for Oscar
Slaters legal fees like hey we helped
you get out of jail you should pay us
back with all that money you got oh yeah
which maybe it depends on not cool Doyle
um you know what I mean you owe his
money like I said maybe it's kind of and
look Arthur Conan Doyle didn't need the
[__] money all right he was he wrote
[__] Sherlock Holmes he was hugely
famous he was hugely successful he was
very rich and it's like this seems a
little petty just gonna say um you know
what I mean just seems a little
petty so he's like well that's what I
would have done if I was in the same
situation like just show the
appreciation and blah blah blah now
Oscar Slater and I can't blame the dude
um he's like no it's like it's stupid
that I even had to pay for this appeal
in the [__] first place which yeah I
agree with you on that he's like so why
should I have to pay all you guys back
it's like I shouldn't even had to pay
for this appeal in the first place um
it's just I I don't know like so I kind
of feel like Doyle was like well it's
like oh the dude we spent all these
years like campaigning for him and it's
like he's ungrateful and I was like the
dude was in [__] prison breaking
Brocks for like 18 give him a [__]
break God damn it you owe him yeah it's
like I and that's the shitty thing it's
like I thought you guys were just
helping him because it's like oh my my
God this is an innocent man and I feel
bad I would not expect him to pay me
back that is [__] up yeah I'd be like
I just believed in your cause and I was
helping you I didn't expect anything in
return yeah that's Skeletor says love
you guys thank you Skeletor ah we love
you too Karen Lee said something but I
don't know what she is she took I don't
know what she said she took it
away who's Karen Lee I don't remember
Karen Lee yeah yeah she's been here
before she's been here before okay
something like she said me too Jen but I
don't remember what that was that was a
yeah a long time ago yeah so the fact
that Arthur corid Doyle thought that he
would and and and him particularly did
not need the money but him saying it's
like oh you should pay your supporters
back because you know you're ungrateful
or whatever I'm just like man shut the
[__] up shut the [__] up um needs his
money man stop it yeah I was just like
he's been in prison for 18 years for
some [__] he didn't do leave the dude
alone holy crap I just can't imagine
like I said if maybe that was office of
of Arthur Conan Doyle no he said that he
wrote a letter listen to this give me my
money [__] he wrote a letter to Oscar
Slater later on and this is a quote from
the letter direct quote you seem to have
taken leave of your senses if you were
indeed responsible for your actions then
you were the most ungrateful as well as
the most foolish person whom I have ever
known what cuz you didn't give him money
yeah because he didn't pay his
supporters back like after he got the
settlement oh I give him a couple
hundred
bucks I don't know I read that and I was
like man Arthur and Doyle maybe maybe
Doyle knew that he would get a
settlement and was [__] vying for
some of that [__] although like I said
Arthur Conan Doyle was like super rich
he did not need the money but um for him
it seemed like more a question of Honor
like he's just kind of like oh well
that's what I would have done but he
just like to show my appreciation for
everybody like you know sticking their
necks out for me and stuff like that but
it's just L like I don't know like I
said if I
was okay if Oscar Slater was like alive
right now and like this had happened I'm
like man that's some [__] I'm going
to give like $10 or whatever it is like
for you know to help that dude out
because that's [__] up Jeff yard has a
important question there uh didn't
Houdini have a huge falling out with
Conan Doyle I'm beginning to see why
yeah and I was just going to bring that
up because we did a show a long time ago
which is one of my favorite shows and
probably we should like revisit this
topic because I'm super into it um
Houdini and Arthur conand Doyle were
really close friends but they had a
falling out because and I was about to
bring this up Arthur con and Doyle I
love the Sherlock stories and this is
hilarious to me because Arthur conand
DOA was very very logical and like he
wrote Sherlock Holmes very logical but
man that [__] would fall for any
stupid spiritualist crap that you came
up with he believed in like all this
[__] all these mediums and like fairies
and all this other kind of crap like we
did a show about like the cotting Le
fairies and all of the um like the
seances and [__] like that like Houdini
made well he didn't make a career out of
it cuz he had a real career but he had
kind of a sideline well you know being
like an Illusionist or whatever and an
escape was the manad by the way but he
had he was I love I love Houdini but um
but yeah he's like a big hero of mine
actually but um he had a sideline in
exposing fake psychics not because he
was an [__] um Houdini actually
wanted to believe that there was life
after the death he just didn't um he was
just he didn't want people profited on
charl yeah he just didn't want people
taking advantage of people who were
grieving yeah um and you know giving
them false hope that their dead
relatives were talking to them and [__]
like that he thought that was shitty in
the 1920s [__] had a [__] ton of
grifters oh big a lot of them they were
good at they were really good at it and
what's funny is that that one movie that
we saw was about the 20s Psychology was
used by grifters a lot to get what was
the name of that movie we saw that
[__] was excellent which one the one
where they had the damn psychologist and
the magician going at it
remember what else he actually he
actually abil billionaire who killed
them girls hired him to [__] talk to
the spirits remember and it turned out
that that wasn't a spirit it was another
grifter pretending to be a dead girl oh
he came out of the came out of the damn
[__] remember that and they had the
damn [__] not the [__] what do you call
it the damn what do you call not a [__]
a [__] god what are you talking
[__] geek they had the Geek The Geek
was nothing more than a damn heroin
addict they were making him eat dead
living chickens and [__] oh the GMA Del
Toro movie we just saw not too long ago
yes yeah yeah that was what was the name
of that thing um nightmare alley
nightmare alley nightmare alley
nightmare alley you got that was that
was a remake actually remake nightmares
alley that [__] was really good we saw
it in the theater yeah I liked that a
lot and uh I love that kind I love that
time period I love that um that whole
time period That's where hudini and all
these guys came from yeah where there
wasn't much difference between an
Illusionist a [__] magician a psychic
and a psychologist and they were all
grifting well see that's why I was
always a big fan of um hini I was always
a big fan of like um James Randy and
people like that because I always
thought that if you're going to have
somebody bust seances and like people
that are taking advantage of people who
are grieving and [__] like that get a
[__] magician they know all the
[__] tricks yeah because like people
that are you know psychologists or other
kind of scientists or just members of
the public they might not know all of
these tricks that magicians know yeah
but all of those fake psychics well like
there's any other kind but like the fake
psychics that were doing the the seances
and [__] back then they absolutely knew
all the same and you could see nightmare
alley the Remake that was a 2018 maybe
2019 maybe yeah it was a couple yeah
around there dudes a murder no maybe
newer maybe newer than that 2020 we just
saw in the theater like maybe 2021
something like that dude murders his
stepdad [__] and then joins a
carnival and when he gets into the
carnival learns all these [__] skills
learns the skills of a psychic but he's
a [__] charlatan but he he can make
all kinds of money with
it then he falls under the he meets
billionaires then he falls into falls
falls into the Trap of a [__]
beautiful psychologist chick who's also
mind [__] Rich dudes uh that was what
was that actress's name uh she's the one
that play that that was Kate Blan wasn't
it I thought was it that girl that I
thought it was the girl that played
Black
Widow I forgot who it was great [__]
flip man I'm pretty sure it shows you
how how you can [__] Swindle people
with your [__]
mind well and they did a lot and they
did they were doing it back then well
like I said I really I'm really into I
love that whole time period of like all
of the the height of spiritualism and
seances and everything because all of
that stuff as much as it was all Flim
Flam which it absolutely was yeah um
effective flam flam it was it worked
really good but like I said that's kind
of why Houdini took it upon himself to
get in there and [__] with that because
well like I said he
wasn't he was a skeptic for sure but he
wanted to believe in life after death he
just was like well I need proof of it
yeah him and his wife best even had a
thing it's like hey whichever one of us
dies first we had they had a preexisting
message yeah you know then that would
prove it to him but he didn't think any
of these um psychics were legit and he
was mad because they were taking
advantage of people who were grieving
and vulnerable and he thought that was
shitty yeah so he's like well I'm going
to go in here and like bust and like try
to show the public it's like don't fall
for this kind of stuff they're just
taking advantage of you yeah um so
that's you know so I admire that a lot
but he was a magician so he knew all of
the tricks that they were using and that
movie we talked about nightmare alley
the newer one see that Tammy said the
original movie is good also yeah is a
good I was didn't see the original
wasn't it it was based on a novel was it
not I'm pretty sure that the well and
obviously the original movie was based
it's good for giving you a a situational
awareness that professionals no matter
how friendly they may seem and how
professional they may see could be could
be total [__] artists all right and
uh psychology when I was a kid back in
the
70s psychologists were not considered to
be scientists they were considered to be
[__] basically
charlatans the real version of that
would be a
psychiatrist they considered them to be
real but they never considered psych
they can prescribe drugs and they they
do like bra they study brain science and
all event but psychology is very
effective the CIA uses it a lot it's a
way of manipulating a victim and see
that movie they'll show you how it's
done and it's a form of Illusionist like
a
magician get
they frame things and how to make
propaganda how to control the
Mind great movie loved
it well like I said you can see why a
lot of magicians are Skeptics themselves
because they know how easy it is to
manipulate people and to get people to
yield yeah like and it's not really even
that hard
no no but yeah I mean that's the thing
yeah so that was with the big rivalry
between Houdini and Arthur kand Doyle
which like I said we did a show about
Houdini um a long time ago like I said
it it was probably like our fourth or
fifth show it was probably like [__]
seven years ago or something Ken says
that was a good show yeah and it's like
I kind of want to revisit that topic and
maybe expand on it a little bit because
I really do like that whole time period
I like that whole but yeah Arthur conand
Doyle as into logic and you know he was
very good at writing his Sherlock Holmes
stories which were very based in
deductive reasoning and stuff like that
he didn't seem super good at it himself
or I don't want to teach he couldn't
practice it yeah he he wasn't he didn't
apply it in his own life I will say
because he fell for some stupid [__]
yeah the fairies story was quite
interesting I saw those photographs as a
kid and it was [__] mesmerized by the
photographs of the fairies they do look
good but yeah they look when you know
how it did it's like so easy it's so
simple how it was done but the thing is
though even as a kid in the [__]
early 80s I'm looking at those going
that's not real no that you know that's
not a real creature they just cut
pictures out of books yeah cut pictures
out of books and stuck them on wire and
like stuck them in the ground yeah yeah
that's all they did aren't real things
that's all I did and then take a picture
of them and Sir Arthur conand do totally
fell for that [__] he it's cuz he wanted
to he wanted to he wanted to believe it
and well and like I said he was very
into and and that was the thing that
kind of ended their friendship as far as
I'm aware is that Arthur konoa was
absolutely adamant that a lot of these
mediums and stuff like that were real um
and Houdini was like no they're just
they're just [__] with you they're
flam artist you're just falling for it
yeah and I think that you know Doyle
couldn't didn't want to accept that
that's all it was that's why they had a
fight yeah Zan said I don't know who
this Doyle guy is you don't know he
wrote Sherlock holes he's one of the
famous most famous dudes in like in
literature yeah he wrote all the
Sherlock holes stories uh he sounds like
he was a real drag yeah
um he's an interesting character because
on the one hand um I admire a lot of his
stances on you know just as you know
we've demonstrated in this case he was
very very interested
in um you know Progressive politics
social justice issues he was very into
trying to um you know get people in you
know that were convicted of crimes that
were innocent he was you know in
campaigning on their behalf so he seemed
like a really good dude um in those ways
but like I said he he really fell for
some dumb [__] so he seemed to like
really have some kind of blind spots
along those lines and when I read that
he had gotten mad at Oscar Slater for
not I don't know if it was necessarily
not paying him back but just paying back
other people that had campaign on his
behalf um because like I said he
obviously did not need the money he was
very wealthy by this time but um he he
seemed to find it like some I don't know
like some kind of
point of Honor that it's like yeah you
should pay back all these people that
helped you and I was just kind of like
that seems like a weird thing to ask I
would never that wouldn't even occur to
me honestly and like when I read that I
was like wow what a douche but yeah so
it was that kind of thing so I don't
know he was a complicated individual uh
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle like I said I
like a lot of the things that he did and
he seemed like a good dude in a lot of
ways but he had some
weird things he had some weird quirks
and a lot of weird blind spots and I I
don't know he was a contradictory person
I guess like we all are but so yeah he
was just a good writer he didn't NE
necessarily have the discipline to apply
any that [__] to himself yeah well and
like I said he
um he campaigned on a lot of like on
behalf of a lot of good causes so he
seemed like a good dude like his heart
was in the right place but as far as you
know falling for stupid psychic [__] and
fairies and stuff like that he didn't
seem like The Brightest Bulb but you
know like I said everybody's full of
contradictions that's kind of what
happens so Oscar Slater got let out with
his money that he didn't ask for I
should note he didn't ask for any money
they just gave it to him so he was let
out um and you have to think this poor
dude he got put in jail he was put in
prison in
1909 and he didn't get let out
until 19 what was it 1927 1928 something
like that so [__] man the world had
changed a lot by the time he got out so
I can't imagine what that was like for
him but so he got out he did remain in
Scotland um even though he wasn't from
there obviously but he never went back
to Germany far as I'm aware um he
actually married again he married
another Scottish woman and he moved to a
Seaside town called air uh on the west
coast of Scotland and uh apparently
there lived very very quietly and an L
until he died in 1948 I believe he was
78 years old so the thing about it okay
now the thing about the murder of Mary
and Gilchrist though obviously Oscar
Slater didn't do it so who [__]
did uh it's still unsolved officially to
this day now eventually um Mary baroman
who was the 14-year-old girl who said
that she had seen the killer uh in the
street it almost bumped into her stuff
like that she later did come out and say
that she had made the whole story up uh
she hadn't even been in the street that
day she hadn't seen Jack [__] um she
said the only reason that she told
police that she had been there and had
seen the killer was because her drunk
ass mom had told her to go to the cops
and tell her she was involved in the
case and maybe they could get some of
that uh sweet reward money U that was
the only reason she did she hadn't
really been there that day she hadn't
seen anything s say he's never read
Sherlock I to be honest I don't really
think you're listen much movie would
probably be better the few that I've
read have actually been quite good um I
read Sherlock Holmes what was it called
The Adventure of the Speckled Band I've
read Hound of the basker Bells I've read
um like some other like I've read some
of the stuff I actually quite like them
but you know it's mystery type maybe
they're in acquired taste but I I
actually quite like them I haven't read
them all I've read maybe a handful okay
if you're listening to the program
recorded uh and you're enjoying the show
please uh give us a uh with super thanks
you can uh what is it there's a little
button you'll see it yeah there's a
little button on the on the replay so
just got just got to plug that yeah well
thank you very much for plugging that
I'm just plugging that yeah okay thank
you because we always forget to talk
about super thanks I know well I get
carried away yeah I know I get carried
away and being like interested in the
stories you know what I mean yeah and
this story like I said I found this
story like really interesting because I
love stuff like this yeah um but I mean
somebody got murdered that's terrible
but you know what I mean it was a long
time ago so so yeah so Mary Baran
obviously made up her whole [__]
story she didn't see Jack [__] she
didn't see anybody in the street that
day because she wasn't even there so who
was this AB person that was named in the
police reports now uh John trench the
detective who worked on the case he
thought uh that it was again Maran
gilchrist's uh nephew Dr Francis
charteris one of her
nephews now they asked him about it they
did ask him about it later and he said
no that wasn't me but you know of course
that's what he's going to say now I will
note that if the killer was indeed uh Dr
Francis there it has been speculated
that police knew this because like I
said that that was the name that um that
lamb that um Helen lamby gave to the
cops because she recognized him hey it
was you know it was Dr
chartes and they were like no it
couldn't have been him
they think that they covered it up maybe
because he one he was a doctor and two
he was friends with a lot of kind of
higher-ups in the government so they
might have just said well you couldn't
have seen him it must have been this
other this lowlife German Jew over here
Gambler person like much easier to pin
it on that dude than some kind of higher
up level of the Gentry or
whatever now there's also some theories
there was another book that came out a
little bit later on that said that the
crime might have been committed by two
men maybe um Dr
charteris and maybe
um Mary and gilchrist's
brother-in-law might have also been
involved CU here's the thing they found
out later on now Mary and
Gilchrist uh let's put it this way she
wasn't on real good terms with any of
her family members she was kind of um a
loner she was a little bit of a recluse
it's like
she didn't really get along with her
family and she had inherited all this
money from her
father and this was kind of a big source
of contention between her and her
sisters because they didn't really get
anything and there's also speculation I
don't even know if it's speculation they
might know this for sure but Mary and
Gilchrist allegedly had an illegitimate
daughter when she was young um who for a
Time worked as her maid but they were
like super super close so a lot of
people speculated that was probably her
daughter but she wasn't
married and not long before she was
murdered she had actually changed her
will to give all of the money to this
maid who was thought to be her
illegitimate daughter and that woman's
daughter who would have been her
granddaughter now it has been speculated
that because maybe some of the other
family members knew that um the will had
been changed they thought they were
going to go in there and like confront
her about it or take some of the
paperwork from her house cuz like I
said when she was murdered the only
thing
taken was that piece of paper which they
don't know what it is from that wooden
box that had all this other paperwork in
it and some people have speculated too
that the only reason that that other
Diamond brooch was stolen which was the
only piece of jewelry that was stolen
was maybe because oh we'll make it look
like a robbery so we'll take this one
thing that was just laying here you know
what I mean so it could have been that
like I said I don't know what that paper
was now Sir Arthur kandoo was like oh it
must been a will but the thing about it
is that if you have a copy of a will in
your house like an official will is also
you know lodged with your solicitor or
whatever it is so there's another copy
of it some place else so somebody just
can't bust into your house and take it
oh I've got your will you know what I
mean so it must have been some
other paperwork you know what I mean
that had something else to do with
something but so I think over the years
the theory has grown that whoever killed
her was probably a family member because
one they point out it was likely someone
she recognized she let them in there was
no forced entry so obviously this was
somebody that she knew that came into
her house two it did really did seem
like the person that came there didn't
come there intending to kill her
necessarily because she was killed with
like I said a weapon of convenience or
was maybe killed accidentally and then
they're like oh [__] you know we knocked
her out or we knocked her over and now
we have to kill her for real or she's
going to like you know knark on us or
whatever so there was that kind of
situation too so that's why a lot of
people speculated that maybe it was a
family member and the fact that she had
just changed her will to give all of her
money cuz she was 83 you know she
probably wasn't going to live much
longer to give all of her money to this
quote unquote made that a lot of people
speculated was her illegitimate daughter
so it's like so some people were kind of
like well maybe some people came in
there to steal some paperwork and you
know see if they could figure out what
was going on there was that kind of [__]
too so um so yeah so some people
speculated that it was maybe not only Dr
charteris Who was her nephew but also
maybe her brother-in-law whose name was
Austin Burell who I believe was the
mother of the niece that lived down the
street um because they think maybe it
was two people
because there was a thing where you know
on the chair that she was beaten to
death with yeah see um there was a
handprint there was a bloody handprint
on it and they were like okay well if
the person that came in the house
looking for the
paperwork there was no blood anywhere
but in the dining room so like if the
person like killed her and then went
looking for the paperwork there would be
blood in that bedroom cuz that was a
separate room so they speculate that
what might have happened was that one of
the people went into the bedroom looking
for the paperwork while the other one
hung out in the dining room with her
they got in a fight you know whatever
happened he hit her she fell over
whatever and he's like oh [__] we have
to kill her now and like beat her to
death and then got his handprint on it
and then you know what I mean and then
he was in the other room and he didn't
get any blood on him so that might have
happened too I don't know if that's the
case but that was kind of one theory
that was put forward that maybe it was
like two people but most most of the
theories nowadays hinge on this was
somebody that was a member of her family
and killed her maybe accidentally maybe
not intentionally because they were
looking for a particular piece of
paperwork that had to do with her estate
and where it was going like after she
died which makes a lot more sense to me
than I think the fact um you know the
the concept that Oscar later got
railroaded into being convicted for this
crime was you know oh well he was known
to be like a like a jewelry like dealer
you know what I mean and maybe dealt in
stolen jewelry and things like that but
had it been him he would have stolen
some [__] she had jewelry all over that
[__] place you know what I mean
thousands of dollars worth of it nothing
was taken except for that one brooch so
to me that leads me to believe that the
person that broke in or that didn't
break in that just came in was looking
for something else not that you know
what I mean yeah and it was somebody she
knew for sure the typical Mo for break
for you know like forcible entry where
you're breaking in you run in there with
a
team you do something
like pull the [__] bed sheets off and
throw them on the [__] center of the
ground then start ransacking the
place just pulling drawers out turn them
upside down anything useful you throw
that into the middle of that
sheet and then you know you might have a
couple different teams in different
rooms doing that and then when
everything's done you just pick up the
sheet throw it over your [__]
shoulder and run out of there throw it
into a car or
something
it's forcible entry or just you know
where you just robing a place you rans
sack it you're not going to be in there
for long that's not what happened here
no not not by a long shot yeah nothing
was ransacked except for the only stuff
that was Disturbed was in the spare
bedroom where she kept that paperwork
they knew exactly what they were looking
for you know what I mean that wooden box
was broken open so that means it was
somebody that they knew so it was
somebody she knew well and the cops knew
that because they're like look she
wouldn't have let a stranger in it she
just didn't do that kind of [__] she was
super paranoid so it must have been
somebody that she knew that came over to
talk to her about something and like I
said it doesn't seem to me that they
came there maybe intending to kill her
but they maybe came there intending to
like confront her about hey what's the
deal with changing your will or
something like that um maybe she got mad
about it they got mad about it and [__]
ensued it it seems like that's more
likely to me
than a random robbery because like I
said it doesn't seem like a robbery
nothing was taken other than that one
thing and that one thing just seems like
and I don't think as far as I know they
never found that diamond roach that was
stolen from there
and I'm kind of thinking they just took
that as just kind of like oh we'll make
it seem like a robbery here I'll stick
in my pocket and then I'll [__] leave
you know what I mean yeah it just seems
more like that they were looking for
something that was in that box like a
paperwork cuz they knew exactly where it
was they went right to it right they
nothing else was [__] up in the house
nothing so somebody she knew it was it
had to be somebody she knew somebody she
said something to this dude yeah knew
where it was yeah so the fact that this
poor [__] spent more than 18
years in prison for this even though he
didn't know this woman at all yeah he
lived down the street from her but he
never seen her before like he didn't
know who she was yeah he was a Jew yeah
he dealt in jewelry he was a little bit
of shady character
maybe
but like I said that doesn't mean [__]
he's not a killer for sure at at least
he didn't get hanged that's all I can
say cuz that would have really sucked it
sucks enough him having to spend like 18
[__] 18 and a half years at prison
for some [__] he didn't do um but at
least he got out he got he got married
to a nice lady and lived quietly on the
coast of Scotland for the rest of his
life and I guess it was all all right
but he might have changed his name name
later I'm not really sure if he did or
not but yeah that's that's some messed
up [__] it just makes me so sad that it
makes me so sad that he was
so shocked that that had happened to him
you know what I mean yeah I mean I get
it like I said it was probably like to
him it just kind of came out of the blue
but that's just it's [__] up how that
could happen even when it when he
clearly didn't do it it's just messed
up the system man it is yeah well and to
be honest um as far as I know this case
is still taught in Scottish law schools
to this day as they should teach you
yeah let's not do this anymore which
became an archetype of what not to do
yeah it well it's still very famous as
like one of the worst miscarriages of
Justice ever because like I said
Scotland very much Prides itself on the
fairness of its uh Judicial System yeah
so the fact that this egregious
miscarriage of Justice happens is really
like a stain on their reputation so they
do kind of um so this is quite famous
you know what I mean and you know I I'll
[__] I'm GNA say it
again the English system of justice it
goes back hundreds of years starting off
with the Magna Dam Carter that even the
king had to follow some rules okay
[__]
um really has helped the United States
because we we basically inherited the
same basic principles to Justice and it
works it works better than the way it
used to okay well yeah uh in the
Medieval era [__] you could get
convicted on Fast fantasmal evidence
like you could be charged for conducting
Commerce with the devil how the [__] do
you prove that how do you prove some
invisible [__] came and told me
she did it oh all right fair enough yeah
I had an invisible cat told me that you
you sold your soul to the devil yeah how
are you going to [__] yeah and they
took that [__] serious [__] seriously
back then they took it seriously okay
that kills me so you know the British
system said no there's not going to be
any of that there's only physical yeah
let's let's not do that yeah and there
so there's a lot of [__] that got rid of
that um the problem today if you ask me
is our Jewelers I think
AI could could do a better job but you'd
have to test it and prove it with with
cases to see if AI could come up with a
better verdict like in other words you
give it a false case you
know in this scenario who actually did
it and see if AI if they figure can
figure it out right that's how you do it
you just keep checking it before AI came
along I was always kind of more of an
advocate of like professional
jurors um at least people who were
schooled in the law they kind of knew
the ins and outs of stuff I don't know
if just having random [__] off
the street that aren't smart enough to
get out of jury duty professional jurors
better um is really the best way to go I
don't know if I would I would want to
trust my life or death professional
jurors would be better but the danger
would be is that you could bribe the
jury because you know the professional
juror so you might be able to make a lot
of money as a that is a that is a these
people are [__] corrupt AI doesn't
have a concept of money it doesn't give
a [__] Bri it that's what I'm thinking
of so yeah that you might be able to
train AI to sniff out who's guilty and
who's Innocent but you have to test it
with fake cases where you the author of
the case knows who's guilty and then you
know you put out the evidence and you
just train AI to to do it and I bet you
you'd come real close bet you'd be
better than a juror than a
jury I gotta just got a weird feeling
they're saying they're saying that AI is
doing things that they never predicted
like they used to say well yeah AI will
be good at building cars and doing tight
no man [__] what AI is good at right
now is making art and poetry and doing a
law emergent property emergent property
yeah they didn't realize that AI could
do that but AI is doing things
that doing things that humans are known
for doing but better weird it didn't go
the way they
predicted well nothing ever does really
that's why I think making predictions is
a waste of time yeah so I think just lay
back and see what happens and now I
would would give the defendant a choice
you could have a human jury or you could
have an AI judge and a jury I actually
you could have a human judge but an AI
jewry and if if if they prove to me that
an AI jewelry couldn't be
rigged and that it has a [__] higher
success rate of [__] coming up with
with a proper verdict I'd choose
AI because you know it's impartial
yeah I mean I guess it would depend on
the case side quester points out problem
with AI is it excludes the compassion
and ethical moral decisions juries may
have um that have nothing to do with the
law that's the thing I think that's
maybe the only downfall because there
might be some cases where there's kind
of like some gray area the jury is just
there whether not you did it or not
there's no compassion there you don't
need compass that might come in the
sentencing phase sentencing at point you
might want to defer to a judge because
you can like bring up exonerating
circumstances you're not understanding
what I'm saying you use AI to find out
whether or not a guy actually did it or
not but that does have anything to do
with sentencing you could have you could
be sentenced by a human judge yeah
because even if you did it like I said
there might have been exonerating
circumstances like well we'll give you a
lighter sentence or we'll let you off on
it or something like that so yeah it
might have to be two different things
got I
we I don't know man like I said if I was
in Oscar Slater situation which I can't
even oh my God that'd be horrifying but
the thing about it is that it could
happen it could happen because look at
this poor [__] he was like I
said he was just on a ship going to New
York it's like hey I'm going to go out
to San Francisco and do some [__] like
my gambling open a gambling club or
whatever and then all of a sudden like
he gets off the boat and he's like
[__] arrested hey you murdered some
[__] he's like I don't I don't know who
that is but yeah so it was that kind of
situation and he's just had no idea what
was going on so if that happened to me
and I was given the option I'd probably
take the a option
to well especially if it was like this
you know what I mean if it was very
clearly so much evidence that I mean
even the evidence that brought him to
the police's attention in the first
place they knew that that like they
found out that that wasn't even the Pawn
ticket with the brooch that wasn't even
it wasn't the same
brooch they knew it wasn't and they went
after him anyway at that point I just
kind of feel like it was like I said I'm
not a big conspiracy theory person but
at this point it did seem like a little
bit of a conspiracy and the thing about
it is that I think maybe it was because
they knew that the actual killer was
probably allegedly her nephew and he was
kind of like of a much higher Social
station
than Oscar Slater was clearly so and
maybe was friends with some of the cops
and like was kind of friends with
higher-ups in the government and stuff
like that so they were just kind of like
yeah we're just going to pin it on this
dude you know he's an immigrant he's
Jewish no one's going to Care he's a
petty criminal so we're just going to
pin it on him we we don't want to pin it
on this highlevel member of society
who's a doctor and everything like that
so we're just going to pretend that
didn't happen I think that's what
happened in this case it was a little
bit of a conspiracy yeah I think like
some of the cops knew who he was and
they just didn't want him to get
convicted so they just pinned it on this
poor
[__] which is that's super
shitty I just feel really bad for this
dude really bad me so what end up Happ
with him eventually oh oh were you not
here yeah I was probably yeah he got out
he got the money okay um he married
again he married a nice Scottish lady
all right and he moved to a Seaside town
in Scotland called air okay and uh Liv
there the rest of his life he Liv he
died at 78 of natural causes apparently
so um you know very very quietly lived
out the rest of his life can't blame him
but like I said his case is still used
as a test case in uh law schools as far
as I know um as yeah let's not do
this that's like a negative
example okay so there any question
if not Karen Lee said he paid them off
yeah maybe I I kind of feel like that
was what happened in this situation
because I feel like the cops knew the
person that did it the nephew maybe
allegedly and he was kind of a high
Mucky muck he was a doctor he was kind
of up in the Gentry he knew a lot
of influential people so they were like
ah he couldn't have done it must have
been this good we'll just pin it on this
dude you know I think it was that kind
of situation which is uh that's pretty
sucky okay so what's our next show going
to be do we know yet does it come up on
the U no the poll if you're not on our
patreon or a YouTube member because if
you're on our patreon or if you're a
member of the YouTube channel you can
vote on what the next topic is going to
be the polls go up on Friday
mornings at 10 a.m. eastern standard
time yeah and they run all weekend they
close uh Sunday at noon Eastern Standard
Time I usually put up five different
topics and I let people vote on them and
then I usually announce it on Sunday as
soon as the always looking for new
patrons that too yeah that too um but
yeah so like I said you can vote on the
on the stuff and um so I don't know I
won't know until Sunday afternoon okay
what the new topic is but Danny Rolland
is Danny is saying hopefully it's a
paranormal based show it might be I try
to put like both things I try to put
like a paranormal show I try to put like
True Crime I try to put like a like a
combination of topics and every time
somebody gives us a topic I always write
it down and I put it in the list and I
try to put it in the to see what wins
you know what I
mean um but tomorrow I might if I have
time I might do a stream on the limouse
Golem which is a movie from I believe
it's from 2017
and I don't remember I have to look up
like who it was that suggested it to me
but I watched it and I wanted to do a
review of it because it's really really
good um so I might do a stream on that
tomorrow if I have time then Friday
night we're going to do our Sidetrack
show um and it's going to be a pregame
because I think momento is okay M Frid
probably talking about the videos that
we cut oh yeah yeah we made some new
erotic video Yeah in public yeah we've
been trying to do like in public outdoor
stuff yeah yeah yeah they they were
pretty good I haven't they came out okay
I I haven't seen it yet I shot I mean it
was our first day yeah it's our first
day to doing it we go out of the park
and get into all kinds of trouble
driving Jenny around she's in the front
seat doing all kinds of crazy [__]
[__] oncoming traffic well the
oncoming traffic is like watching yeah
we did all that kind of stuff I I might
upload them tomorrow okay but um yeah we
found a good spot like to film
some naughty out
yeah stuff where like not that many
people we were we were out on these
docks at a park near where we used to
live it was nice it's nice yeah had nice
[__] Florida
atmosphere got Jenny out on the dam
[__] park bench out on the docks
doing stuff I'm [__] I'm I'm being
the lookout you know just like wide open
it's wide open and then across the lake
man there's [__] matches and [__] on
the other side
yeah yeah yeah it's and then [__] I'm
we going to go we going to [__] we're
going to [__] knock out we're going
to [__] the [__] out of each other over
there when we get ready yeah yeah we get
we'll get to it but uh we're just
scouting out some areas where uh because
we were noticing on some of the services
that uh that outdoor stuff and public
stuff gets a lot of
hits and you we're kind of up for that
[__] I've been I've been kind of w do
some stuff like that that seems like fun
it's fun yeah and like I said we found
there's a park I'm not going to say what
it is but there's a park near where it's
beautiful where we used to live yeah um
that about 10 m 15 miles from here yeah
yeah that has like some good like the
way it's situated I had never actually
been up in there until yesterday yeah it
actually has some like really good areas
where it's like man you could get up to
all kind of stuff in here and like
probably no one would see you if you
came like you know during times when it
wasn't busy yeah there is some danger
though well yeah I mean you never know
like when we first got there there was a
dude they fishing yeah they're up there
so it's like so we had to wait for him
to leave you know what I mean but then
after that it was like it was pretty
much okay but we kept like looking
around like we kept hearing stuff I'm
like was that a squirrel what was that
yeah so we might put it up yes tomorrow
yeah it'll be I edited them today but
I'll show them to you tomorrow before I
you can find us on 13 cam on Mini vids
and 13 cam spelled out all right 13 team
cam one word on Min vids yeah and
vids.com I we got three good videos yeah
yesterday we might probably open up a
couple more accounts might do a PornHub
account we probably also do a [__]
xHamster account yeah put all that stuff
over there well because I thought about
doing that because then you could post
like teasers for free and then you could
come have people come over and like buy
the longer stuff yeah Tammy said you can
do all the outdoor stuff you want where
I live very remote yeah yeah yeah I mean
around here the thing about public
videos though yeah is that part of the
Kink is that you have to be able to see
that there's like that there are people
that there are people in the background
like you have to like see people in the
background or hous or cars or something
so it's like even if people can't
actually see you um then cuz I kind of
feel like if you're just out in the
middle well I don't know like some
people do like just people in the woods
and [__] like that but it's just
we could find places to do that but yeah
I think people get off more on you know
it's like hey I'm on the highway doing
this stuff and like people could look in
the car and like see what I'm doing you
know what I mean I think people like get
off more on that there's got to be some
danger there involved yeah doesn't
matter though yeah we we just wave
because thousands of hundreds of people
see it on the internet anyway thousands
of and the thing about it is I kind of
feel like look when I'm driving around I
don't notice what other people are doing
in their cars they could be doing all
kind of crap in there as long as you're
in your lane and I'm in my Lane you
could be I almost [__] went off the
road a couple
times well see that's kind of the dang
trying to watch the camera at the same
time make sure everything's good and
[__] well because we did a couple
where I was shooting it like with my
phone but he wanted to do one where he
was shooting it from the driver's seat
like but he just had a camera on like on
a stick I had it on a stick yeah cam
yeah it came out good but action cam
stuff came out good at a better at
higher res it came out okay yeah it
looked pretty good but I still had to
turn it so it's still like a phone video
how how's the audio it sounded all right
to me okay good I mean I'll listen to it
again tomorrow but it sounded okay like
you can hear a lot of car noise but we
don't have a [__] ton of experience with
the action cams yet yeah we're just
we're just like trying them out we have
them on a stick but um I don't know so I
don't know we'll see how it's like I
said yesterday was our first experience
we were like just driving around yeah
pretty much all afternoon like we're
going to put we're going to put put up
they won't cost much probably 10 10
bucks each probably not even not how
long are they well one of them is about
s minutes okay cuz it got edited down
all right yeah one of them's about I
don't know they're they're all about
five to seven minutes okay but yeah you
edited a lot out no I didn't you didn't
okay well there was some stuff that I
shot that I couldn't use okay um you
know what I mean seemed like we were
recording for like an hour no it wasn't
okay Quest here said um I drive all day
at work and generally I see some weird
[__] when I'm driving and I just have to
keep driving yeah yeah I'm sure all
people are doing well like I said I
don't I don't notice what people are
doing most of the time so I kind of like
figure well most people probably aren't
paying that much attention I feel
like I don't know I wasn't really
bothered even when we were like in the
Park yeah and like it was it was wide
open yeah and I was just kind of like
whatever well you knew nobody was coming
in I had a damn I had a damnn lookout
yeah yeah but still I could see him
coming for a while but you know what I
mean you don't know if the houses can
see you I didn't really care [__] him I
didn't care I'm just like man they can't
see that far whatever unless they got
binoculars in which case she had fun
though she enjoyed it had a good time
it's not fake it's real I had a good
time but yeah it's just
like I thought I'd be I thought I'd be
bothered and I
wasn't she's funny man whenever what
whatever when whenever we do something
new she she gets a little nervous uh I
can tell in her body language she's a
little nervous to do it but then she she
gets into it it's F it's funny like
uh today she was like I had to cut some
of that out [__] I look like a
linebacker in there my [__] shoulders
and [__] no what happened is because
because of your new [__] training
routine you lost a lot of weight on on
the bottom half of you you're not as
[__] your shoulders and [__] are not
as big as you think they are it's in
your mind well to me it looks well part
of it is is is you know what I mean you
walk with confidence you
[__] that's that's part of it you I'm
to punch a [__] you were not
yeah you were not really kind of like in
uh super [__] mode where you're [__]
walking like a well and I'm not I'm not
like a little wilting Wallflower either
right yeah
so girls learn to walk that way in
modeling school I'm a bad [__] girl
girls learn to walk that way in modeling
school and then strippers learned to
walk that I never went to that [__] you
didn't go to that [__] maybe I should
send you that some of that [__] nah so
when you [__] get ready when you when
you get ready to [__] do your [__]
you go right into [__] stripper mode
and [__] you know I know you can
deliver I mean you can dance so I know
you can do it I know but like I
said I don't know all the stuff I shoot
like comes out really good but it's
because you are playing to yourself
through through through the Monitor and
I know what looks good you know what
looks you see it happening right but you
know like uh when you have stage
training you know me me being ex theater
and stuff you know how the audience sees
you you know how a camera sees you so
you have to click into a new mode to do
that because things that look good in
camera they're not nor they're not
natural well no of course not you got to
do weird [__] right it's part of
theater you can't just do regular [__]
in the camera it looks terrible it looks
[Laughter]
terrible you know what I mean but it
doesn't look terrible in real life it's
just that when it's recorded it doesn't
look as good
yeah well aella said that well yeah I
mean everybody knows when when you're
doing cam stuff it's real artificial
yeah you have to be right you can't just
do regular [__] like you be doing in
your real life which like I said if
somebody was there with you it wouldn't
nobody would think about it but on
camera you really have to like be
careful you got to play to the camera
what position you're in like what angle
you're at it's like it's exhausting yeah
it's not it's not easy you can't just be
no can't be natural no you have to like
you have to do all of this it's theater
unnatural [__] you have to move
unnaturally you have to like but
right
what's py says there's one guy who has a
cop car I see around and he took the cop
decal off and now it says thought Patrol
okay
yeah oh no I mean like I said wait one
of the videos that we shot um we were
driving it's not like a super super busy
but I don't know it's kind of a busy
highway where's thought where's thought
control from thought Quest here where's
she from side quest here I don't know
what are you talking about no I'm just
asking where she's
from but
um I don't know I wasn't that bothered
but I was still kind of like when a when
a semi truck went by I was kind of like
oh that [__] can probably see in this
car but he wasn't looking though so I
kind of like squatted down we just
making his day though I guess yeah he's
like hey he be on the [__] he get on
the [__] radio man I saw hot she's
[__] doing all kinds of [__] in the
front seat I saw this girl's tits and
she was doing all kind of [__] in the
front feet yeah right you're were
probably older than him yeah probably so
it doesn't really matter well you know
thanks for reminding me that's I love
being reminded I love how I love being
reminded how old I am but you're a
cougar though you're a super
cougar but yeah it was fun we'll do
we'll do that again we had a we had a
good time yesterday driving around doing
this she from Sacramento I used to go up
Sacramento all the time I was a kid I
was originally from Carson and then I
moved to Long Beach for a while left
California in 1981 then mve went to
Brazil I went to Southern California
Military Academy stma yeah still got
friends on here some from the
academy a lot of my family still lives
there California
yeah all right so are we ready to wrap
it up yeah cuz what is it it's almost qu
to 11 probably to go to bed soon yeah
you used go up there for horse shows my
mother was a famous trainer in
California so she still trains horses to
this day she just went today and trained
some horses I almost went to school
almost went to school in
ohigh with all the celebrity kids long
time
ago yeah that's another story I'll tell
that story another time yeah save that
for Friday yeah I save that for
Friday like I said we probably got all
kind of fun stuff to talk about FR we'll
talk about all kind of fun stuff all
right so it's qu to 11: we should
probably go to bed so cuz we're kind of
sick so we should probably like get some
sleep uh so yeah thanks everybody for
dropping by this evening this was a
fascinating case and I had a really good
time talking about it so thanks to
whoever recommended it I think it was
Victor but if I can't remember at this
point because it was a long time
ago um but thanks to whoever it was all
right so we will see you guys again on
Friday night for the Sidetrack show I
might be on to stream tomorrow doing a
movie review on the Lim housee gold but
we'll see how that goes um if I have
time uh so yeah if I don't see you
tomorrow then I'll see you again on
Friday night good now